START THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
FINANCE TODAY AS OUR. FINANCIAL
AID HEARING WE KNOWS THERE'S A
LOT OF ENERGY IN THE ROOM
EVERYONE LIKES TO TALK ABOUT
FINANCIAL AID EVERYONE'S HAPPY
ABOUT.
THE.
WHAT THE ISSUES THAT WE FOCUS
ON HERE AND YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE REALLY PROUD THAT WE
SPENT? OVER TWO BILLION DOLLARS
EVERY YEAR TO A LOW INCOME
STUDENTS
ATTEND COLLEGE.
WE HAVE OF COURSE ARE OUR
WORKERS PROGRAM IS THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM SERVING OVER THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
EVERY YEAR COVERING TUITION.
FOR MOST OF THE STUDENTS.
WE HAVE OUR FIVE YEAR OLD MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM
SERVING MORE THAN FIFTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS EVERY YEAR. WRITING
TUITION DISCOUNTS FOR BOTH LOW
INCOME AND MIDDLE INCOME
STUDENTS.
THAT WE'VE ALSO STEPPED UP THE
LAST. FEW YEARS WITH THE AYE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FINANCIAL AID
NOW PROVIDING ALMOST A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN AID TO PAY
FOR. BOOKS HOUSING AND OTHER
COTS.
BUT WE KNOW THAT DESPITE. THESE
INVESTMENTS.
NOT NEARLY ENOUGH TO ANY GAP
STILL EXISTS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSAND LOW INCOME STUDENTS
DON'T QUALIFY FOR CAL GRANT OR.
THOSE THAT DO.
ITS NOT THE TUITION THAT REALLY
HAMMERS THEM IT'S THAT HOUSING
AND TRANSPORTATION AND BOOKS.
FOOD THE OTHER HALF COSTS OF
COLLEGE SO WE STARTED THIS
DISCUSSION TWO YEARS AGO TO LOOK
AT HOW WE COULD. REIMAGINE
FINANCIAL AID LOOK AT THE
REALITIES WOULD IT COST TO
ATTEND COLLEGE A CONTINUE THAT
SERVING MORE STUDENTS IN OUR CAL
GRANT. AND MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS
BUT THINK ABOUT WAYS HOW WE CAN
FUNDS OF THE NON TUITION. AT
COST SO WE HAD WE BEEN WORKING
ON THIS AS I SAID FOR TWO YEARS
WE ASK THIS DEBATE COMMISSION
TO.
COMMISSION A US STUDY TO LOOK AT
OPTIONS AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HERE TODAY BIG PART OF THE
AGENDA TODAY WE'RE LOOKING AT
THAT.
AS WELL AS OTHER AND
MISCELLANEOUS FINANCIALLY AND
CAL GRANT ISSUES SO BUT FOR TO
TODAY'S HEARING.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL PROCEED.
SO THE FIRST FIRST ISSUE WE'RE
NOT GONNA TAKE ROLL JUST YET NOT
A QUORUM HERE.
THE FIRST ISSUE ISSUE NUMBER ONE
REFORMING CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
WILL HAVE A PANEL.
SYSTEM WHO ARE PART OF OUR
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM IMMIGRANTS
TORT ONE CHAIRS WE HAVE TO
FIGURE IT OUT REAL QUICK.
GO GET YOUR FROM NEXT TO US
ANTI.
SO MAYBE THAT LUPITA YOU CAN
HELP THE US ARTISTS OFTEN AND
FRAME THE ISSUE WE'RE. TALKING
ABOUT TODAY SIR.
BUT YOU BE THE COURT THERE'S
LIKE A LOT OF THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION. THANK
YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS WERE
HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY.
TO TALK TO YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT OF THE REPORT THAT BOB
SHARMAN WITH THE CENTURY
FOUNDATIONS AND THE BOMB AND
OTHERS WERE ABLE TO COMMISSION
WITH ME TODAY TO IS OUR CHAIR
LANDET I JUST SAY.
WHO'S HERE ALSO TO HELP PRESENT
SO THE ISSUE AT HAND REALLY IS
THAT YOU KNOW. I I CAME ONBOARD
ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO TWO YEARS
ABOUT FEW MONTHS AND.
THE ISSUE AROUND FOOD AND
HOUSING IN SECURITY FOR STUDENTS
AND THE COST OF ATTENDANCE HAS
REALLY.
REALLY SUNSHINE SKYROCKETED.
THE ISSUE HAS BALLOONED INTO
I'M REALLY ANALYZING WHAT IT IS
THAT WE DO AS A STATE TO HELP
SUPPORT STUDENTS WITH FINANCIAL
AID AND HOW EASY IS IT TO
UNDERSTAND AND ADMINISTER.
AND AS WELL AS DOES THAT MEET
THE NEEDS OF THE STUDENTS SO
WERE US SEEING THAT STUDENTS ARE
SUFFERING FROM FOOD AND HOUSING
AND SECURITY SOME STUDENTS ARE.
NOT GOING ON TO COLLEGE BECAUSE
THEY EVEN WITH THE AID THAT THE
STATE PROVIDES AS JENNER SAID IT
IS AND IT IS THE MOST GENEROUS
IN THE NATION.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH BECAUSE OF OUR
COST OF ATTENDANCE SO.
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO I REALLY
WANT POP TO GOING TO GOING TO
SOME OF THE.
COMPONENTS OF THE REPORT AND
THEN OUR CHAIR LODDIGES IS GOING
TO GO INTO SOME OF THE
PROPOSALS.
THAT WE WOULD SUPPORT IN THE
IMMEDIATE AND THEN I'LL GO INTO
THE SECOND AND THIRD PHASES OF
OF THE ROADMAP.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE STARTED OUR WORK ON THIS
REPORT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION WITH
UMPQUA PULLING BACK THE LENDS A
LITTLE BETTER IN RECOGNIZING
THAT THE UNDERLYING PER EVERY
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT. AS A
POTENTIAL COLLEGE STUDENT AND
THINK ABOUT HOW OUT WHAT ROLE
CAN THE FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM
PLAY IN MAKING IT POSSIBLE FOR
EVERY. ANY CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
WHO'S INTERESTED IN COLLEGE TO
BE ABLE TO ATTEND AND TO BE ABLE
TO ATTEND IN A WAY THAT CAN BE.
SUCCESSFUL FOR THEM IN ORDER TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE. THAT.
FAMILY FINANCIAL SITUATIONS ARE
NOT A BARRIER TO IBM ALL TO
ATTEND COLLEGE IT MEANS THAT
THOSE POTENTIAL COLLEGE STUDENTS
NEED TO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
VIABLE OPTIONS.
AVAILABLE TO THEM THAT THOSE
ARE AFFORDABLE.
AND THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE. DECISIONS ON A TIMELY
BASIS BASED ON THAT INFORMATION
SO WHAT MATTERS WHEN THEY HAVE
THOSE KIND THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION.
OUR WORK OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS RESULTED IN EVERY REPORT
THAT YOU THAT YOU HAVE OR HAVE
ACCESS TO IT IS A LENGTHY SO I'M
NOT GONNA GO INTO A TO EVERY.
DETAIL.
TO GIVE YOU SORT OF A SENSE OF
WHERE IT WHERE IT INTENDS TO GET
TO. AFTER FULLY IMPLEMENTING
EVERYTHING THE REPORT THERE ARE
REALLY TWO MAIN THEMES ONE IS.
FOR THE FOR CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
TO HAVE ADEQUATE FINANCIAL AID
ENOUGH GRANT AID SO THAT THEY DO
NOT HAVE. THE NEED THEY CAN GO
TO COLLEGE WITHOUT THE NEED TO
EITHER WORK EXCESSIVELY OR TOLD
OR TO BORROW THE.
BEYOND WHAT IS A REASONABLE
AMOUNT TO BORROW ALL AND
PREFERABLY TO NOT HAVE TO BORROW
AT ALL IF WE CAN GET TO THAT
POINT THAT IN OF ENOUGH. GRANT
AID IS ONE GOAL THE SECOND GOAL
IS FOR THAT GRANTED A TO BE
DESIGNED IN A WAY THAT IS.
EFFECTIVE AND IN ORDER FOR IT TO
BE EFFECTIVE. WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE TIMING AND CONTENT
AND DELIVERY OF INFORMATION.
TO THOSE POTENTIAL COLLEGE
STUDENTS IN THE STATE.
IS THIS IS SUCH THAT PEOPLE CAN
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT THINGS LIKE
WHETHER TO WHETHER TO CONVEY
THEIR TO CONSIDER A FOUR YEAR
COLLEGE OR A CAREER TECH PROGRAM
KNOWING WHAT'S AVAILABLE TO
THEM.
KNOWING THAT THEY CAN UP CAN
APPLY AND COULD POTENTIALLY
AFFORD YOU SEE CSU PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WHETHER TO ATTEND FULL TIME HOW
MUCH TO WORK.
AND BEING ABLE AND HAVING THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED DEBT IN
ORDER TO DECIDE WHETHER TO APPLY
TO COLLEGE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
A LOT OF.
MUCH OF THE BE.
OPERATIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION AND AT.
OPERATES NOW ON THE WAY THAT THE
SYSTEM IS DESIGNED.
IS TOO LATE
TO INFLUENCE THOSE DECISIONS
MUCH OF IT COMES AFTER PEOPLE
ALREADY APPLIED AND WE'RE
TELLING THEM HOW MUCH THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR OUR IN EIGHT AROUND
AND WHETHER THEY'VE AFTER
THEY'VE. JUST MADE THE DECISION
TO APPLY TO YOU SEE YOUR CSU WE
NEED TO GET AHEAD OF THAT AND
MAKE SURE THAT A FAMILY THAT
MIGHT BE WRONGLY ASSUMING. THAT.
UC RCS YOU ARE PRIVATE COLLEGE
IS NOT AFFORDABLE OR A OR A.
UPPER AND MIDDLE INCOME FAMILY
THAT MIGHT BE WRONGLY ASSUMING
THAT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES NOT
AN APPROPRIATE OPTION FOR THEM.
HAS EARLY KAT INFORMATION THAT
CAN HELP TO INFLUENCE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
THE FULL RANGE OF OPTIONS IN
FRONT OF THEM TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE.
THOSE FULLY INFORMED.
DECISIONS.
SO A CORE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
REPORT IS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT A COMMISSION TO ENGAGE
IN A PROCESS OF PROVIDING PEOPLE
WITH EARLY COMPREHENSIVE AND
PERSONALIZED COLLEGE FINANCIAL
AID INFORMATION. THAT TAKES INTO
CONSIDERATION ALL OF THE COLLEGE
COSTS NOT JUST TUITION AND
PROVIDES PEOPLE WITH COMPARATIVE
INFORMATION ACROSS DIFFERENT
KINDS OF INSTITUTIONS. IN THE
STATE GETTING AHEAD OF SOME OF
THE CURRENT.
INFORMATION AND PROCESSES THAT
ARE NOT THAT ARE OUT THERE.
SECOND IS TO AS A PART OF THE
THIS.
CORE RECOMMENDATION IS AN
INNOVATION FUND SO THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION CAN TEST DIFFERENT
APPROACHES TO PROVIDING
FINANCIAL AID AND TEST THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF DIFFERENT WAYS
OF PROVIDING AID.
DIFFERENT PERHAPS DIFFERENT
AMOUNTS IN DIFFERENT. KINDS OF
CIRCUMSTANCES SO THAT KIND OF
GETS AT THE INFORMATION AND
EFFECTIVENESS SIDE OF OF.
IMPROVING FINANCIAL AID.
THERE WE ALSO HAVE A NEED FOR
MORE FINANCIAL AID AND.
THERE WE ARE RECOMMENDING AND
INCREASED.
STATE INVESTMENT.
PARTICULARLY NEEDED AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ALSO SOME NEED AT.
AT C. S. U. YOU SEE IN THE AND
THE AND THE PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS.
BUT WE HAVE HIGHLIGHTED IN
PARTICULAR WHERE WHERE THE
BIGGEST GAPS ARE ARE AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND.
WE ARE RECOMMENDING A
COMPREHENSIVE OVERHAUL AND
SIMPLIFICATION OF CAL GRANT IN
GENERAL THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO TAKE A LITTLE BIT MORE
TIME IT CAN'T BE IMPLEMENTED
THIS COMING FALL PEOPLE ALREADY
HAVE THEIR FINANCIAL AID AWARDS
AND EVERYTHING.
BUT ONE FIRST STEP THAT CAN BE
TAKEN IS TO IN IS TO.
EXPAND THE.
CAL GRANT BE ACCESS AWARD.
WHICH LARGELY GOES O A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS SO WE
SEE THAT AS A FIRST STEP TOWARD
WHAT WOULD THEN BE.
A MORE COMPREHENSIVE A
CONSOLIDATION OF CAL GRANT A. B.
AND C..
WE'RE RECOMMENDING ELIMINATING
THE USE OF OF GPA AND.
TIME OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL AND AGE
LIMITS.
AGAIN SO THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT EVERY POTENTIAL COLLEGE
STUDENT AND SO THAT WE CAN SEE
EVERY EVERY CALIFORNIA RESIDENT.
AS A POTENTIAL COLLEGE STUDENT
AND A POTENTIAL COLLEGE.
GRADUATE.
I'M GONNA STOP THERE THERE'S A
LOT MORE DETAIL.
THAN THAT BUT.
TRADED OVER TO. LONDON THAT
RIGHT.
THANK YOU. I THINK YOU CHAIR
MCCARTY FOR HAVING THIS HEARING
MY NAME IS LANDED JUST SAYING
I'M THE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
STILL NAY COMMISSION AND I'D
FIRST LIKE TO START BY THANKING
OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE CENTURY
FOUNDATION. OF FOR THEIR
EXPEDITED WORK ON THIS REPORT.
WERE VERY GRATEFUL TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
IN THE INTEREST OF PROVIDING
BOTH THE COMMISSIONERS AND
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE LEGISLATURE
ENOUGH TIME TO FULLY CONSIDER
THE POLICY AND PROGRAMMATIC IN
THE FISCAL IMPLICATIONS OF THE
REPORT. WE DECIDED TO ACTUALLY
AT THE BAPTIST DO NAY COMMISSION
TO TAKE THE REPORT AND KIND OF
THREE PHASES.
PHASE ONE REALLY SPEAKS TO WHAT
WE CAN DO IN THE NEAR TERM
PARTICULARLY GIVEN I'M CURRENT
BUDGET PROPOSALS FACE TO WE WILL
BE CONSIDERING THAT ARE ARE
MEETING IN JUNE. AND THAT REALLY
IS THE LARGER PART WHICH
CHARMIN SPOKE OF RELATED TO
CONSOLIDATION AND HOW WE THINK
ABOUT THE VARIOUS MEANS OF RULES
AND REGULATIONS THAT SOMETIME
FORM BARRIERS FOR STUDENTS
ACTUALLY EVEN WANTING TO APPLY.
OR UNDERSTANDING WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE ELIGIBLE AND THEN THE
THIRD PIECE THE THIRD PHASE WILL
REALLY SPEAK MUCH BROUGHT MORE
BROADLY TO ISSUES RELATED TO THE
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE. AND
WHAT WE AS A STATE CAN DO TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT JUST
DODD MEETING STUDENTS NEEDS IN
TERMS OF FEES AND OR TUITION BUT
THERE WERE REALLY LOOKING AT
WHAT THE COST DRIVERS ARE. THAT
PREVENT STUDENTS ROM ATTENDING
COLLEGE AND TRYING TO ENSURE
THAT THE STATE'S INVESTMENTS IN
STUDENTS ACTUALLY SPEAK TO THOSE
TO THOSE ISSUES. SO JUST TO GIVE
YOU AN OVERVIEW OF WHAT WE'VE
FOCUSED ON A LAST WEEK WE MET ON
APRIL THIRD THOSE WHO NAY
COMMISSION AND WE ENDORSED WHAT
WE ARE THINKING OF US FACE ONE
WHICH REALLY CALLS FOR FIRST.
AND AS MR FIREMAN MENTIONED
INCREASING THE CAL GRANT BE
ACCESS AWARD.
IT'S REALLY AIMS TO TACKLE SOME
OF THE ISSUES RELATED TO
AFFORDABILITY.
AND TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE
WERE ALSO LOOKING VERY MUCH OF
WHAT WE CAN DO IN THE NEAR TERM
RELATED TO IMPROVINGI'M
FINANCIALLY OUTREACH AND EARLY
INFORMATION SO THAT FAMILIES AND
STUDENTS. KNOW MUCH MORE ABOUT
THEIR FINANCIALLY OPPORTUNITIES
MUCH EARLIER ON AND I WILL SAY
THAT AS WE THOUGHT ABOUT THIS
WORK IT WAS IMPERATIVE TO ASK.
THAT WE CANNOT USE SOME DESIGN
THINKING PRINCIPLES IN THINKING
ABOUT THIS THAT WE TEND TO I
THINK AT THE STATE LEVEL THINK
ABOUT WELL HOW ARE WE GONNA
ADMINISTER THINGS. AND WHICH ONE
TO PUT THAT ON ITS HEAD A LITTLE
BIT AND REALLY THINK ABOUT WHAT
IS A STUDENT CENTERED APPROACH.
SO THINKING ABOUT FINANCIAL AID
HOW WOULD HOW COULD IF WE START
WITH THE STUDENT AT THE CENTER
OF IT HOW WOULD THAT CHANGE HOW
WE WOULD ADMINISTER. THIS ENTIRE
PROGRAM AND HOW WOULD THAT
CHANGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS. FROM
THE THIRD PIECE THAT THE
COMMISSION ENDORSE LAST WEEK WAS
REALLY AROUND AND INNOVATION
FUND WHICH WE MENTIONED WHICH IS
REALLY ALLOWS US TO THINK ABOUT
HOW CAN WE TEST.
HAVING CAMPUSES BE MUCH MORE
FLEXIBLE IN ADDRESSING VERY
SPECIFIC CHALLENGES THAT
STUDENTS FACE IN TERMS OF
FINANCIAL AID.
STAGE TO WHICH WILL ENTERTAIN
AT OUR JUNE MEETING REALLY IS
FOCUSED ON CONSOLIDATION AND
TAKING THE CAL GRANT A BNC AND
THE MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP AND
THINKING ABOUT HOW TO WE
CONSOLIDATE THOSE INTO ONE.
SIMPLE STREAMLINED PROGRAM OF
THE IDEA IS TO MAKE FINANCIAL
AID MUCH MORE ACCESSIBLE TO
STUDENTS BUT ALSO TO THINK ABOUT
HOW DO WE  SOME OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS BOTH AT
THE LEVEL OF THE CAMPUS. AS WELL
AS AT THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
ITSELF.
THAT PROPOSAL REQUIRES A LOT
MORE CONSIDERATION WE REALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
CLEAR ABOUT ISSUES RELATED TO
THE CONSTRUCTION ELIGIBILITY AND
AWARD AMOUNTS. AND THAT WERE
ABLE TO INCORPORATE FEEDBACK
FROM VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING STUDENTS THE SEGMENTS
AND OF COURSE LEGISLATORS.
AND THEN WE INTEND TO ISSUE A
COMPREHENSIVE CONSOLIDATION
PROPOSAL.
THE END OF OUR JUNE MEETING
WHICH.
WE HOPE THAT CAN BE ADOPTED IN.
THE CURRENT LEGISLATIVE CYCLE
OR FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN
LEGISLATIVE CYCLE. THE THIRD
STAGE REALLY IS A SUBSTANTIAL
OVERHAUL OF OUR FINANCIALLY
SYSTEM BECAUSE THAT REALLY
SPEAKS TO A HOLISTIC APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING ISSUES RELATED TO THE
CAPITAL COST OF ATTENDANCE.
WE THINK THAT THE REPORT THE
PROPOSAL FROM THE CENTURY
FOUNDATION COULD BE TAKEN ON THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY YEAR. AND
BY DOING THAT WE WOULD BOTH
TRIED TO DEAL WITH I'M COVERING
COSTS OF TUITION AND FEES AND
BEYOND THAT THINKING ABOUT. FOOD
AND HOUSING NEEDS WHICH WE KNOW
ARE REALLY DRIVING THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ALSO WANT TO FURTHER
STUDY THAT YOU HAVE SEEN MODEL
TO DETERMINE THE COST THAT
FINANCIAL AID ELIGIBILITY.
PROPOSED.
BY THE CENTURY FOUNDATION
REPORT.
AND WE'LL CONSIDER A
COMPREHENSIVE FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAM OF PROPOSAL THEN THAT
MEETS THE NEEDS.
AND THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND CONSIDERS ALL OF
THOSE THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS.
ONCE WE'VE ADDED ALL OF THAT WE
WILL CERTAINLY BE RETURNING TO
THE LEGISLATURE WITH A CUP MORE
COMPREHENSIVE PROPOSAL FOR HOW
WE WOULD LIKE TO. THINK ABOUT
THE STREAMLINING OF FINANCIAL
AID WITHIN THE STATE AND I'LL
LEAVE IT TO PAPA EXECUTIVE
DARKHAWK ALLOWED TO GET INTO
MORE OF THE DETAILS.
THANK YOU SIR IN TERMS OF.
THEY CAN APPRECIATE THE REPORT
THE EXPEDITED FASHION AS WELL.
I THINK IT ALL FOR YOU OF THE
VERY FIRST PROPOSAL WE TALKED
ABOUT IS INCREASING THE BE
ACCESS WARD. AND SO THIS IS OUR
MAJOR STATEWIDE A PROGRAM THE
SURPRISE A PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
NON TUITION EXPENSES IT'S CALLED
THE CAL GRANT BE ACCESS WORD AND
IT KID. OF BE USED TO FIND AYE
NON TUITION EXPENSES LIKE
TEXTBOOKS EDUCATIONAL SUPPLIES
HOUSING TRANSPORTATION FOOD.
CURRENTLY THAT AMOUNT.
IS ABOUT A THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY TWO PER YEAR FOR THE
ENTIRE YEAR WHICH INCLUDES A
BASE CRAP ABOUT. A THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT PLUS AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FOUR DOLLARS
UP BECAUSE OF THE.
COLLEGE ACCESS TAX CREDIT.
SO ACCORDING TO HISTORICAL
SOURCES HOWEVER IT AT THAT SEE
SEX AS BEEN ABLE TO OBTAIN THE
ACCESS AWARD WAS SET AT NINE
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND THAT WAS IN
THE NINETEEN SIXTIES.
NOW THE AMOUNT EQUIVALENT TO SIX
THOUSAND TODAY IN AND I IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ADJUSTED FOR
INFLATION DE INFLATION AND SO WE
KNOW THAT THE COST OF. OF THAT
THE VALUE OF THAT. ACCESS AWARD
HAS NOT KEPT UP WITH THE CAR
TO INFLATION.
FOR OVER TWO HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS RECEIVING THE
ACCESS AWARD EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THE AWARD IS ONE OF VERY FEW
SOURCES OF FUNDING FOR NON
TUITION EXPENSES THE STATE AS WE
MENTIONED IS INCREDIBLY GENEROUS
WITH. OF THE.
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN TUITION
ASSISTANCE BUT WERE NOT AS.
JENNER'S PARTICULARLY IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE AND HOUSING AND FOOD.
AND THAT'S WHY YOU'VE SEEN SO
MANY REPORTS AND SO MANY
STUDENTS SUFFERING LIVING OUT OF
THEIR HOUSES ARE OUT OF THEIR
OUTSIDE OF AND ANY HOUSES AND
MAYBE IN THE CARS. WARREN.
ON THEIR FRIENDS COUCHES AND SO
AND SO FORTH.
SO WITH AN INCREASE IN THE CAL
GRANT BE ACCESS AWARDED CARRIES
WITH IT OF SUBSTANTIAL FISCAL
IMPACT OF THE STATE SO.
.
WE COULD PAY IT BUT IT COULD
PAYS. SIGNIFICANT DIVIDENDS IN
TERMS OF FOOD AND HOUSING
SECURITY AND REDUCING STUDENTS
RELIANCE ON DEBT WHICH WERE ALSO
VERY CONCERNED WITH. THE
COMMISSIONING COURAGE IS THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROMOTE
APPROPRIATE OF FUNDING IN PHASE
ONE OVER THREE YEARS A TO
INCREASE THE CAL GRANT BE
ACCESSIBLE OR STARTING IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND WE DO HAVE
SOME. FIGURES ON THAT IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN TERMS OF IF YOU
WERE TO ENTER CREASE AT EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED THE FIRST YEAR AND
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED THE SECOND
IN THREE THOUSAND OR AND OR
STARTING DEPENDING ON ANY ONE OF
THOSE AMOUNTS FROM THREE
THOUSAND. OF TO SIX THOUSAND WE
WE HAVE THOSE AMOUNTS FOR YOU AS
WELL.
THIS SECOND PART OF OF THE
PROPOSAL THAT WE'RE READY TO
SERVE TAKE ON IS.
THAT WE COMPLETELY SUPPORT AND
BELIEVE IN IS THE OUR REGION
EARLY INFORMATION COMPONENT OF
THIS SO THE REPORT. HAS
RECOMMENDATIONS CONSISTENT WITH
OUR CURRENT EFFORTS WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO DO MORE OUTREACH TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES WE ALSO
JUST HAD THIS AND AND. THIS LAST
YEAR WE IMPLEMENTED THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN INITIATIVE BECAUSE WE
REALIZE THERE'S A A DEEP GAP
BETWEEN A STUDENTS OF COLOR AND.
IN CERTAIN COMMUNITIES ANNA IN
APPLYING FOR THE FACTS OR THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT AND
MATRICULATING ON TO HIGHER
EDUCATION.
SO WE WOULD LIKE TO INCORPORATE
PERSONALIZED INFORMATION ABOUT
EIGHT ESTIMATES INCLUDING
FEDERAL STATE AND INSTITUTIONAL
EIGHT INTO SEE SEX
COMMUNICATIONS AND PUBLIC
OUTREACH MATERIALS SUCH AS THE
PRELIMINARY AWARD NOTIFICATION
LETTERS AND THE NET PRICE
CALCULATOR. THAT WILL BE PART OF
A MODERNIZE WEB GRANT SYSTEM NOT
THIS NOT IS NOT INFORMATION THAT
WE'D BE MAKING UP THIS IS
INFORMATION THAT WOULD BE
DERIVED FROM. CURRENT CAL GRANT
ELIGIBLE INSTITUTIONS NET PRICE
CALCULATOR ALREADY ON THEIR
WEBSITES THAT WE WOULD JUST BE
PULLING INFORMATION TO PERSONAL
PERSONALIZED INFORMATION PERSONS
CURRENTLY. THIS THIS YEAR WAS
THE FIRST YEAR THAT WE ADDED IN
ADDITION TO CALTRANS PELL GRANT
INFORMATION SO WE'D REALLY LIKE
TO PROVIDE STUDENTS MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT. A COLLEGES OR
UNIVERSITIES THAT THEY THEY
WOULD LIKE THEIR FINANCIALLY
INFORMATION SO THAT THEY CAN
COMPARE IT BEFORE THEY EVEN YOU
KNOW EVEN GET ADMITTED.
TO THESE UNIVERSITIES SEES ACT
WILL PROPOSED.
A BUDGET FUNDING FOR A
PERMANENT A DEDICATED OUTREACH
UNIT YOU CAN BELIEVE THIS WE
REALLY DON'T HAVE A DEDICATED
OUTREACH UNIT. A AT THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION SO WE HAVE OF
FOLKS THAT ANSWER PHONES FOR A
FROM A LOT OF STUDENTS WHO ABOUT
EIGHT TO TEN FOLKS TO DO THAT
AND THEN WE HAVE ANOTHER SMALLER
UNIT THE ANSWERS ALL THE
INSTITUTIONAL.
COLES AND ADMINISTERS THE EIGHT
AND DOES THE TRAININGS FOR HIGH
SCHOOL A COUNSELORS AND FOR
COLLEGE COUNSELORS THAT AND
THAT'S A BUT TEAM OF ABOUT THREE
OR FORCED.
THE INDIVIDUALS AND SO WE REALLY
DON'T HAVE A DEDICATED STAFF TO
DO THIS AND.
WE WOULD WE WOULD BE SEEKING
FUNDING TO DO THAT UP SO THAT WE
CAN CONCENTRATE EFFORTS ON
STUDENTS OF COLOR RURAL STUDENTS
FOSTER YOUTH.
AND OTHER OF A DEDICATED OTHER
SPECIALIZED AYE GROUPS THAT ARE
NOT CURRENTLY BEING SERVED AS
WELL.
WE WOULD ALSO PROPOSE STATUTORY
LANGUAGE REQUIRING SEES ACADEMIC
OUTREACH EFFORTS TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES AS EARLY AS PART OF A
POSSIBLE REGARDING THEIR
ESTIMATED ELIGIBLE. FEDERAL AND
STATE INSTITUTIONAL AID.
PROVIDING PROVIDED RELIABLE
ESTIMATES CAN BE ATTAINED YOU
KNOW WE WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING STUDENTS WITH
ACCURATE INFORMATION AND THAT
WE'RE NOT CAUSING MORE OF
CONFUSION OUR PROBLEM.
AND THEN THE THIRD FOR A
PROPOSAL THAT WERE READY TO MOVE
ON IS THE IN A WEEK VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF HIS THE INNOVATION
IN FINANCIAL AID. RECOMMENDATION
SO INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES MAY HAVE
INNOVATIVE NEW IDEAS FOR
ENHANCING COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
IN REDUCING THEIR STUDENTS
OVERALL COST OF ATTENDANCE BUT
MAY NOT HAVE YET TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE A STATE GRANT OR LITTLE
INCENTIVE FUNDING TO DO SO. SO
THE PROPOSAL TO ESTABLISH AN
ADMISSION INNOVATION GRANT AND
MANAGED BY C. SECT WOULD ALLOW
THE STATE TO NOT ONLY FINANCE
BUT EVALUATE AND CONSIDER. THE
MERITS OF A PILOT PROPOSALS AT
THE CAMPUS LEVEL AND WE'RE NOT
CALLING IT THE CHRISTIAN.
INNOVATION GRANT BUT WE DID GET
THE INNOVATIONS ARE IDEA. I'M
NOT SURE I'M NOT SURE ABOUT GOT
IT FROM HE'S TURNING RED BUT.
IT IS A WAY TO.
INCENTIVIZE AND PROVIDE ON
DOLLARS FOR INNOVATIVE IDEAS ON
CAMPUSES IN THE COULD BE
ANYWHERE FROM THE HIGHER
INSTITUTION WANTING TO REACH
INTO K. TWELVE AND OTHER
OUTREACH AND AND REALLY TO HELP.
THROUGH THE PROVIDER OF SOFTER
HAND OFF ON A COULD ALSO BE INS
AND HIGHER ED INSTITUTIONS THAT.
WANT TO TRY A MEAL PLAN FOR ALL
STUDENTS BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
HIGH OF YOU KNOW LOW INCOME
STUDENT POPULATION OR OF PROVIDE
SOME OTHER MEANS BY WHICH
STUDENTS CAN AFFORD TO HOUSING
YOU KNOW AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE.
ALSO SOME CAMPUSES HAVE
EXPERIMENTED WITH EMERGENCY AID
PROGRAMS FOR MUCH NEEDED SUPPORT
UP FOR STUDENTS AT RISK OF
DROPPING OUT OF BECOMING
HOMELESS IN THIS WOULD GIVE.
THEM AN OPPORTUNITY REALLY TO
TEST THAT OUT.
.
THE OTHER ISSUE CHU IS.
SOME HAVE IMPLEMENTED SUCH AS
SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY
IMPLEMENT PROGRAMS RECORDS TUNES
TAKE MORE THAN TWELVE UNITS FOR
INSTANCE.
THEY COULD DIRECTLY INCREASE ON
TIME.
GRADUATION.
TO ENCOURAGE DECISIONS TO DO
THAT IN THIS WOULD PROVIDE THAT
SEED MONEY TO TO OFFER REALLY.
EVIDENCE BASED BEST PRACTICES.
SO UNDER THIS PROPOSAL THE
COMMISSION WOULD RECEIVE AN
ANNUAL ALLOCATION FROM THE STATE
BUDGET AND ADMINISTER GRANTS TO
INSTITUTIONS BE A COMPETITIVE
APPLICATION. PROCESS THAT MA
WITHOUT WOULD WANT TO EXPERIENCE
WITH INNOVATIVE APPROACHES TO
FINANCIALLY AND AS A CONDITION
OF RECEIVING THESE DOLLARS
CAMPUSES WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
PERFORM AN INDEPENDENT
EVALUATION OF THESE PROGRAMS OR
WE COULD DO THE INDEPENDENT
EVALUATION AS WELL.
OF THE OUTCOMES ON AND TO HAVE
A REPORT BACK TO THE COMMISSION
TO SEE WHICH WAY IT WHICH.
INNOVATIVE PRACTICES REALLY
YIELD THE BEST RESULTS THE
COMMISSION COULD THEN REPORT
OUTCOME SO LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION ON ANY VALUABLE
EVIDENCE THAT. WE FIND.
REGARDING ANY STATEWIDE
PROGRAMS THAT CAN BE SCALED.
THE COMMISSION WILL PROPOSE
STATUTORY BUDGET LANGUAGE FOR
CREATING A FUND FOR INNOVATION
IN COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY HOUSING
IS MINISTERED BY THIS TO NAY
COMMISSION SO THOSE ARE THE
PROGRAM THE THE THREE SORT OF
MAJOR RECOMMENDATIONS THAT. WE
THINK THAT WE IN THE SHORT RUN
CAN.
BEGIN WITH AND THEN AS OUR
CHAIR DISCUSSED THE SECOND FATE
WOULD BE REALLY LOOKING INTO THE
CONSOLIDATION OF THE ACTUAL.
CURRENT GRANT ADMINISTERED ST
GRADE MINISTERED PROGRAMS AND
THEN FUTURISTIC LEE NOT TOO FAR
OFF WE WOULD REALLY NEED TO WORK
WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS HIGHER ED
INSTITUTIONS AND OTHER
INTERESTED PARTIES. ON THE
ESTIMATED FAMILY CONTRIBUTION
AND WHAT SORT OF RATE THE COST
OF ATTENDANCE WHERE WHERE WE
SHOULD ACTUALLY PLACE THAT WE
DON'T FEEL LIKE WE'RE READY AT
THIS TIME TO OFFER YOUR
RECOMMENDATION ON THAT BUT WE
REALLY NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE
TIME ON THOSE.
PROPOSALS.
I THINK. I WILL WILL HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE REPORT AND
THAT FOLLOWED FOR YOU AND AND
HOW WE COULD AT ADDRESS IT.
YEARS TO COME GETS A THIS YEAR
AS WELL BUT WE WANT TO GIVE THAT
SEGMENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO TO
RESPOND TO THIS. AYE WE WE WE
WERE NOT GOING TO HAVE THE THREE
SEGMENTS AS PART OF THIS GOING
IT'S A STUDENT COMMISSION.
DRIVEN FOCUS BETTER REALIZE
THAT.
THEIR SEGMENTS ARE BIG PIECE OF
THIS AND.
.
AND THAT WE WANT INTO YOUR
SEGMENTS ON HOW IT WOULD IMPACT
THE STUDENTS
WCC S. YOU AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM AND OF COURSE WE WOULD DO
WELL TO NOTE THERE ARE. STUDENTS
AT THE.
NONPROFIT PRIVATE COLLEGES AND
FOR PROFIT TO DO I REPRESENT CAL
GRANT RECIPIENTS BUT WE WANT TO
JUST FOCUS ON THE.
BUT THAT THE MAIN THREE TODAY.
SO WHO WANTS TO GO FIRST.
SURE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHRIS
CARTER AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
STUDENT FINANCIAL SUPPORT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND I.
THINK YOU CHAIR MCCARTY AND
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY.
I WORK WITH MY CAMPUS
FINANCIALLY COLLEAGUES TO MAKE
YOU SEE AFFORDABLE ACCESSIBLE TO
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
BUT I'D LIKE TO BEGIN WITH A
BRIEF EXPLANATION OF UC'S
APPROACHED UNDERGRADUATE
FINANCIAL AID WHICH WE CALL THE
EDUCATION FINANCING MODEL.
BECAUSE THE REPORT THAT THE
STUDENT A COMMISSION.
FOR TWO STERN A COMMISSION THAT
YOU'RE DISCUSSING TODAY
EFFECTIVELY SUGGESTS
IMPLEMENTING A PROGRAM THAT IN
MANY RESPECTS IS VERY SIMILAR TO
UC'S BUT I STATEWIDE BASIS SO.
DESCRIBING OUR PROGRAM I HOPE
THAT MAKE YOU SEIZE PERSPECTIVE
ON THE REPORT CLEAR.
SO THE FINANCING MODEL THAT YOU
SEE IS REALLY CROWDED IN FOUR
DIFFERENTPRINCIPLES FIRST
REFRAIN FINANCIAL AID IN TERMS
OF ASSISTING STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES TO COVER. A TOTAL COST
OF ATTENDANCE AND NOT JUST
TUITION EXPENSES THE INABILITY
TO COVER COSTS ASSOCIATED
HOUSING FOOD OF BOOKS CAN BE
JUST AS MUCH A BARRIER. TO
STUDENTS AS AN INABILITY TO
COVER TUITION EXPENSES BUS JUST
MUCH DUST MOST UC FINANCIAL AID
RECIPIENTS RECEIVED GRANT
ASSISTANCE BUT NOT ONLY OFFSETS
TUITION COSTS BUT ALSO HELPED
WITH OTHER EXPENSES.
SECOND RESPONSIBILITY FOR
COVERING COLLEGE COST CENTERS ON
THE PARTNERSHIP NET PARTNERSHIP
INCLUDES PARENTS TO THE EXTENT
THAT THEY'RE ABLE ACCORDING TO A
FEDERAL FORMULA.
STUDENTS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THE STATE AND THE UNIVERSITY.
THIRD WE EXPECT ALL STUDENTS TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE AIR
EDUCATIONAL COSTS BUT THAT
CONTRIBUTION SHOULD BE A
MANAGEABLE ONE.
THUS THE NEED TO WORK AND BORROW
IS CERTAINLY THERE BUT IT NEEDS
TO BE REASONABLE AND GENERALLY
SIMILAR ACROSS UC CAMPUSES. AND
ACROSS STUDENT LIVING
ARRANGEMENTS.
FINALLY SINCE ANY SYSTEM MY
PROGRAM CANNOT ADDRESS ALL LOCAL
AND STUDENT SPECIFIC NEEDS.
CAMPUSES NEED TO HAVE ADEQUATE
FLEXIBILITY LOCALLY TO ADDRESS
LOCAL CIRCUMSTANCES AND
SPECIALIZED NEEDS THAT SOME
STUDENTS HAVE.
SO NOW WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS
TURN TO THE HANDOUT THAT I THINK
I SEE YOU JUST RECEIVED. AND
LIKE TO START WITH FIGURE ONE OF
THE HAND OUT TO SHOW THE E. FM
IN PRACTICE.
SO FIGURE WISELY VISUALIZATION
OF HOW PARENTS STUDENTS AND
FINANCIALLY WORK TOGETHER. AND
ALL THIS DOES NOT CAPTURE EVERY
STUDENTS CIRCUMSTANCES AS THE
REPORT. THEY ARE CONSIDERING
TODAY SAYS NOT ALL STUDENTS FROM
LOW INCOME FAMILIES RECEIVE A
CAL GRANT.
IT DOES BROAD THE REFLECT HOW
YOU SEE HELPS UNDERGRADUATES
FINANCING THEIR EDUCATION.
SO HOW DO THE TAR REALLY
REFLECTS THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE FOR AN AVERAGE
STUDENT LIVING ON CAMPUS OF A
STUDENT'S FINANCIAL AID
ELIGIBILITY IS CALCULATED. WITH
COST UNIQUE TO THEIR CAMPUS AND
LIVING SITUATION.
AND MOVING FROM LEFT TO RIGHT
INSTEAD OF THESE COSTS ARE
MANAGED BY STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
WITH INCREASING PARENT INCOME
LEVELS.
WHILE WE LOOK. AT MORE THAN
PARENT INCOME IN DETERMINING
WHAT PARENTS CAN CONTRIBUTE IN
THIS CASE THE INCOME USED AS A
STRONG PROXY FOR FAMILY
RESOURCES.
SO NOT FIRST THE EXPECTATION
THAT ALL STUDENTS CONTRIBUTE
WITH SOME COMBINATION OF WORK
AND BORROWING SHOWN IN. IN GREEN
AT THE BOTTOM OF THE CHART.
WE ASSUME THAT ALL STUDENTS
WHICHEVER CAMPUS WHICHEVER
LIVING SITUATION WILL CONTRIBUTE
TO THE COST OF ATTENDANCE WITH A
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR AND
MANAGEABLE LEVEL OF WORK AND
BORROWING.
THE CONTRIBUTION FROM PARENTS
SHOWING GRAY IN THE UPPER RIGHT
HAND SIDE OF THE CHART. IS
CALCULATED ACCORDING TO A
FEDERAL FORMULA AND GROWS AS
FAMILY RESOURCES GROW.
AND THEN YOU CAN SEE IN DARK
BLUE WE HAVE THE PELL GRANTS AND
THEN WE ALSO HAVE BEEN IN GOLD
THE CAL GRANTS WHICH OF THE
SINGLE LARGEST GRANT SOURCE FOR
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
WE THEN FILL IN THE REMAINING
GAPS IN THE COST OF ATTENDANCE
WITH YOU SEE GRANT ASSISTANCE.
IF A STUDENT IS NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
A PELL GRANT BECAUSE HERE SHE
HAS EIGHTY FIVE FORTY STATUS FOR
EXAMPLE AND THEREFORE ELIGIBLE
FOR FEDERAL AID. FOR LACK OF
PUBLIC BECOMES A PART OF THAT
GAP
THAT WE FILL IN WITH YOU SEE
GRANT TO RESET GENERALLY
CONSISTENT LONG WORK EXPECTATION
ACROSS STUDENTS.
THE HIGHER THE TOTAL GRANT
ASSISTANCE ACCOUNTING FOR GRANTS
FROM ALL THREE SOURCES.
THE LOWER THE NEED FOR ALL GRANT
RECIPIENTS AT UC TO WORK AND TO
BORROW.
IF GRANT ASSISTANCE FALSE OR OF
COSTS INCREASE IN GRANT
ASSISTANCE DOES NOT KEEP PACE.
THEN THE NEED TO WORK AND BORROW
GOES UP.
PERCENT TAKES US TO FIGURE TWO
WHICH SHOWS WHAT COULD HAPPEN IF
ALL OTHER COMPONENTS OF THE
CHART WERE HELD CONSTANT. AND
CAL GRANT CAL GRANT FUNDING FOR
EXAMPLE RECEIVED BY YOU SEE
STUDENTS WAS WOULD DECLINE.
THIS IS EFFECTIVELY A GRAPHICAL
REPRESENTATION OF THE SCENARIO
REFERENCED IN PAGE EIGHT OF YOUR
AGENDA. AND WITH LESS TOTAL
GRANT ASSISTANCE AVAILABLE THE
NEED TO WORK AND BORROW WOULD GO
UP FOR ALL GRANT RECIPIENTS AT
UC.
SO PRESENTED THE SCENARIO
BECAUSE WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE FINANCIAL IMPLICATIONS OF
THE REPORT FOR YOU SEE STUDENTS
ARE AT LEAST TWO DIFFERENT
RESPECTS.
FIRST THE REPORT DOES SUGGEST
DISTRIBUTING CAO GRANTS TO
STUDENTS TO SET AND NEED TO WORK
CAN BORROW. WORK TURNED IN
AFFORDABILITY TARGET IN THE
REPORT ITSELF AT ABOUT ELEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND CORRECTLY THE REPORT
REFERENCES THIS AS ONE OF THE
UNIVERSITY CALCULATES IS BEING
AND MANAGEABLE RANGE.
BUT HOW TOUGH TO POINT OUT THAT
IS STILL HIGHER THAN THE LEVEL
THE UC STUDENTS CURRENT FACE
CURRENTLY FACE AND THAT'S THE
RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE TO
ROUGHLY ONE THOUSAND DOLLAR
INCREASE.
AND THE NEED FOR YOU SEE
FINANCIAL AID RECIPIENTS TO WORK
AND BORROW ANNUALLY.
AND SECONDLY WERE CONCERNED THAT
WHILE THE REFORM OUTCOME OF A
COMMON AFFORDABILITY TARGET
ACROSS THE PUBLIC SEGMENTS A
SPECIFIED IN THE REPORT.
THE PATH TO THAT OUTCOME IS NOT
CLEAR.
AS DESCRIBED IN YOUR AGENDA FACE
PROCESS FOR ACHIEVING THAT GOAL
DURING WHICH THE OUTCOME IS ONLY
PARTIALLY FUNDED. COULD RESULT
IN YOU SEE STUDENTS RECEIVING
LESS CAL GRANT SYSTEMS AND BY
EXTENSION. INCREASES IN THE NEED
FOR STUDENTS TO WORK AND TO
BORROW.
NOW WE CONSIDER THESE CONCERNS
IMPORTANT PRECISELY BECAUSE THE
STATE SUPPORT FOR THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM HAS BEEN SO TREMENDOUSLY
IMPORTANT FOR YOU SEE STUDENTS.
WHO LOOK TO SOME COMBINATION OF
FEDERAL STATE AND UNIVERSITY
GRANT ASSISTANCE TO HELP MANAGE
THE COST OF A YOU SEE EDUCATION?
I BRIEFLY LIKE TO BEFORE
WRAPPING UP SHARE TO ADDITIONAL
CONCERNS.
FIRST THE ROLE OF THE CAMPUS
FINANCIAL AID PROFESSIONALS IS
REALLY ONLY MINIMALLY
ACKNOWLEDGED IN THIS REPORT. THE
AVERAGES THAT I WORK WITH THAT A
SYSTEM WIDE LEVEL ACROSS THE
UNIVERSITY TO SAY NOTHING OF
AVERAGES THAT WE CAN TALK ABOUT
IT A STATE LEVEL.
AS CONTEMPLATED HERE WE CANNOT
ADDRESS THE SPECIFIC AND UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT SOME STUDENTS
FACE SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. CAMPUS FINANCIAL
AID STAFF AS PARTNERS
GIVEN THE ONLY CAMPUS IS PUT
TOGETHER A FULL FINANCIAL AID
PACKAGE. AND THE CAMPUS STAFFS
ARE UNIQUELY CAP THE UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO COUNSELING WORK
WITH STUDENTS ONE ON ONE.
SECOND TO ADDRESS STUDENT NEEDS
THE CAMPUS IDENTIFY LOCALLY IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CAMPUSES NEED FLEXIBILITY WITH
FUNDING THAT IS CONTROLLED
LOCALLY.
AND SO THE ABILITY TO USE THAT
INSTITUTIONAL FINDING IS
CRITICAL TO ADDRESSING THOSE
LOCAL AND SPECIFIC NEEDS THAT
FOLKS ON OUR CARDS ON CAMPUSES.
CAN IDENTIFY.
FURTHER TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
STATE IS ABLE TO INCREASE ITS
SUPPORT FOR THE CABINETS IN THE
COMING YEAR FOR EXAMPLE INCREASE
IN THE CAL GRANT BE ACCESS AWARD
AS THE PEOPLE JUST REFERENCED.
THEN STUDENTS AT UC AND INDEED
EVERY OTHER SEGMENT ARE GOING TO
BENEFIT.
AND FINALLY I'D LIKE TO KNOW THE
REPORTS CALL FOR PROVIDING
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES A BETTER AND EARLIER
INFORMATION ON COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY.
HE SEES WORK PROMOTE
TRANSPARENCY IN FINANCIAL AID IT
COMBINES INFORMATION ON BOTH
AFFORDABILITY AND PREPARATION
FOR YOU SEE ADMISSION AND EARLY
OUTREACH EFFORTS.
WE'RE CERTAINLY WILLING AND
EAGER TO WORK WITH THE STUDENT A
COMMISSION AND OUR COLLEAGUES IN
THE OTHER SEGMENTS
TRUE VOTE THE AVAILABILITY OF
EARLY. ACCURATE AND HELPFUL
FINANCIAL AID INFORMATION.
SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR FOCUS
TODAY ON PROMOTING AFFORDABILITY
IN CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND ON
BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR
PERSPECTIVE TO.
OKAY THANK YOU BEFORE WE GET TO
THAT SEE IF YOU COULD TAKE.
FALL REAL QUICK.
MCCARTY.
CHAVEZ.
MEDINA.
MURATSUCHI.
VOEPEL.
OKAY PHARMACIST AT WEST.
THANK YOU.
YES YOU.
THINK FUTURE MCCARTY AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU
TO MY HIGHER EDUCATION
COLLEAGUES AND FELLOW PANELISTS.
MANY MS NOELIA GONZALEZ AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF ADMISSIONS AND
FINANCIAL AID AT CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY STANISLAUS.
I ALSO CURRENTLY REPRESENT THE
CSU ON C. SACKS FINANCIAL AID
ADVISORY BOARD AND MANY YEARS
AGO SERVED ON THE GROUND
ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
IT WAS MY PLEASURE TO REPRESENT
THIS CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM HERE TODAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
CALIFORNIA'S TO NAY COMMISSION
FOR THEIR IMPORTANT WORK IN
REVIEW OF CALIFORNIA'S FINANCIAL
AID PROGRAMS.
WE APPRECIATE THAT YOU ARE
TACKLING THIS CRITICAL ISSUE
WITH CAREFUL CONSIDERATION AND
THOROUGH COLLABORATION.
AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY WE SUPPORT THE
CENTURY FOUNDATION REPORTS CORE
PRINCIPLE.
THAT FINANCIAL AID SHOULD BE
EASY AND CONVENIENT FOR STUDENTS
AND FAMILY. AND THAT FINANCIAL
AID TO BETTER SERVE STUDENTS
WITH FINANCIAL NEED.
INDEED THE CHANGES TO
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS
PROPOSED IN THE REPORT WOULD
SIMPLIFY THE PROCESS FOR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES.
AS WELL AS MERGING THE VARIOUS
CAL GRANT PROGRAMS IN THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP INTO ONE
PROGRAM.
REMOVING THE GPA AND EIGHT
REQUIREMENTS USING ESTIMATED
FAMILY CONTRIBUTION INSTEAD OF
INCOME OR ASSETS HEALINGS. AND
ELIMINATING THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN ENTITLEMENT AWARDS.
THOSE AWARDED STRAIGHT OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL AND COMPETITIVE WAR
AWARDS. ALTHOUGH HOW OF THE
POTENTIAL TO MAKE THE SYSTEM
FAIR AND LESS DAUNTING FOR
STUDENTS.
SIMPLIFYING THE PROGRAMS AND THE
APPLICATION PROCESS WOULD BE
MOST BENEFICIAL.
BECAUSE OF THIS POSITIVE STUDENT
IMPACT THE CSU SUPPORTIVE OF
THESE PROPOSALS.
WE ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDATION TO EXPAND THE COG
ROUTE TO MEET STUDENT NEEDS.
BOTH THROUGH FEW MORE WARDS TO
STUDENTS INCLUDING TRANSFER
STUDENTS AND THROUGH POTENTIALLY
LARGER AWARDS.
THAT SUPPORT PRESUMES THAT THERE
WOULD BE SUFFICIENT STATE
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT BOTH AN
EXPANSION OF THE COG ROUND
PROGRAM. AS WELL AS NEW
INCREMENTAL INVESTMENT IN THE CS
YOU SO THAT WE COULD PROVIDE THE
ACADEMIC PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
TO STUDENTS.
IN KEEPING WITH THE SLANT OF
IMPACT TO STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. OF OTHER REPORT
RECOMMENDATIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE IT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WHEN THE STUDENT
HAS QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS ABOUT
THEIR FINANCIAL AID THEY'RE ABLE
TO TALK TO SOMEONE ON THE
COLLEGE CAMPUS TO GET ANSWERS
AND A RESOLUTION TO THEIR
PROBLEMS.
REQUIRING THE STUDENTS TO
INSTEAD DISCUSS ISSUES WITH THE
STATE AGENCY OR ADDING AN
ADDITIONAL LAYER OF BUREAUCRACY.
WILL INEVITABLY CONFUSE AND
DEFLATE STUDENTS WHO CANNOT
MANAGE THE SYSTEM AND THEREFORE
CANNOT GET THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY CONCERNING
FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE THE FIRST
AND THEIR FAMILIES TO GO TO
COLLEGE WHICH IS ONE THIRD OF
THE CSU STUDENT POPULATION. AND
NOT MY PARTICULAR CAMPUS
STANISLAUS REPRESENTS A SEVENTY
PERCENT OF OUR STUDENTS.
ADDITIONALLY.
THE REPORT'S RECOMMENDATION OF
IMPOSING A STUDENT CONTRIBUTION
OF ELEVEN THOUSAND. DOLLARS
REGARDLESS OF THE STUDENTS TRUE
ECONOMIC SITUATION. HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO HARM OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS
STUDENTS THAT HAVE VERY LOW
FAMILY INCOMES AND CHOOSE TO
LIVE AT HOME TO CUT COSTS.
OFTEN CSU STUDENTS WHO WORK
WHILE ATTENDING COLLEGE ARE
USING THEIR INCOME TO HELP
SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES NOT JUST
PAY COLLEGE EXPENSES.
YET THIS WORK EXPECTATION TO
RECEIVE AID WOULD ESSENTIALLY
ELIMINATE THE STUDENTS
ELIGIBILITY FOR CAUGHT GRANT.
INCREASING THE LIKELIHOOD OF
STUDENT BORROWING.
THIS WOULD ALSO HAVE A LARGE
IMPACT AND UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
IS NOT ALL ARE TAKA AND
THEREFORE ARE UNABLE TO WORK.
THESE EXAMPLES HIGHLIGHT THE CS
USE PRIMARY CONCERN ABOUT
SEVERAL OF THE REPORT
RECOMMENDATIONS MAINLY THE
POTENTIAL FOR UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT WOULD HINDER
THE STUDENT EXPERIENCE AND
NEGATIVELY IMPACT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS.
THOSE WHO NEED THE MOST
FINANCIAL SUPPORT.
AS THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDERS HOW
BEST TO SUPPORT STUDENTS AND A
DRESSER FULL FINANCIAL NEEDS IN
COLLEGE. I BELIEVE SUPPORTING
THE EFFORTS ALREADY UNDERWAY ON
CAMPUSES IS AN EFFECTIVE
APPROACH.
FOR EXAMPLE THE REPORT
RECOMMENDS HIRING A TEAM AT C.
SACK TO RAMP UP OUTREACH TO
STUDENTS EARLIER IN THEIR
ACADEMIC EXPERIENCE.
MAKING SURE THEY ARE AWARE OF
FINANCIALLY OPPORTUNITIES.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS TYPE OF
OUTREACH AND ARE ENGAGED IN IT
BOTH AS A SYSTEM THEM AS
INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES.
FOR EXAMPLE AT STANISLAUS WE
HAVE EARLY OUTREACH EFFORTS IN
BOTH OUR FINANCIAL AID OFFICE
AND OUR ADMISSIONS AND OUTREACH
OFFICES. WE HOLD MANY WORKSHOPS
FOR PARENTS AND STUDENTS IN
GRADES SIX THROUGH EIGHT SO THAT
THEY ARE AWARE OF ADMISSIONS
CRITERIA AND THE AVAILABILITY OF
FINANCIAL AID.
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH P. CAME THE
PARENT INSTITUTE FOR QUALITY
EDUCATION.
AS WE THINK PARENTS
ARE AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE
EQUATION AND ARE OFTEN THE FIRST
TO ENCOURAGE OUR CHILDREN TO
ATTEND COLLEGE.
PERRANCE BELIEVE IT IS POSSIBLE
THAT BELIEF WILL TRANSFER TO
THEIR STUDENTS.
AND THEIR CHILDREN.
I AM A PERFECT WORLD ONE WERE
FUNDS ARE LIMITLESS AND HIGHER
EDUCATION WITH FULLY FUNDED. I
WOULD SAY THAT INCREASING
OUTREACH AT THE STATE LEVEL WAS
A GREAT IDEA. THE MORE VOICES
THE BETTER HOWEVER THE REALITY
IS THAT FUNDING IS FINITE AND
THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH HIGHER
EDUCATION DOLLARS TO MEET ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S NEEDS.
AS SUCH I WOULD QUESTION WHETHER
DUPLICATING THESE EFFORTS IS IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE STATE
AND ITS STUDENTS.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS THE CSU BASIC
NEEDS INITIATIVE AIMED AT
SUPPORTING STUDENTS WHO FACE
FOOD AND HOUSING AND SECURITY.
AS PART OF THIS INITIATIVE ALL
CAMPUSES OFFER FOOD DISTRIBUTION
PROGRAMSAND THE NUMBER OF CSU
CAMPUSES OFFER MICROGRAPHS
SMALL FINANCIALLY TOWARDS. TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS WHO FIND
THEMSELVES IN AN EMERGENCY OR
WHO ARE IN DIRE FINANCIAL NEED.
THE BASIC NEEDS INITIATIVE IS AN
EXAMPLE OF A PROGRAM AT THE CSU
THAT IS HELPING ADDRESS STUDENTS
FINANCIAL SITUATION.
ABOVE AND BEYOND THE COST OF
TUITION.
SUPPORTING PROGRAM SUCH DISEASE
THAT ARE ALREADY UNDER WAY AND
ARE HAVING AN IMPACT WOULD HELP
STUDENTS FACING FINANCIAL NEED.
HOWEVER WE WOULD URGE THAT IT
ANY SUPPORT FOR THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS BE ABOVE AND BEYOND
RATHER THAN RE PRIORITIZING. OF
THE LIMITED HIGHER EDUCATION
BUDGET FUNDS.
IN CLOSING I WOULD LIKE TO AGAIN
THINKS HE'S ACT AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR ADDRESSING THE
ISSUE OF FINANCIALLY AND A
COLLABORATIVE MANNER.
IMPROVING FINANCIAL AID SO THAT
IT MEETS THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS
AS A GOAL WE AT THE CSU SHARE WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO BE
PART OF THE CONVERSATION MOVING
FORWARD. THINK YOU.
THANK YOU.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SOME CHRISTIAN US MANY
OF VICE CHANCELLOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION AND
WE THINK THE STUDENT COMMISSION
FOR LEADING THIS WORK.
THE BUDGET REQUEST APPROVED BY
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
LAST YEAR MAKES REFORMING THE
CAL GRANT PROGRAM ONE OF OUR
SYSTEMS TOP PRIORITIES. WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TO
HAVE IT'S LONG OVERDUE AND WE
THINK THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU MOVE THE
SYSTEM IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
YOUR AGENDA AND THE PREVIOUS
TESTIMONY DOES A GOOD JOB OF
HIGHLIGHTING THE CHALLENGES THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS FACE. AND I'LL
REITERATE JUST A FEW POINTS THAT
ARE ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT TO OUR
OFFICE.
AS YOU'RE AWARE THE STATE HAS A
LONG STANDING POLICY TO WAVE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ENROLLMENT
FEES FOR FINANCIALLY NEEDY
STUDENTS USING A DEFINITION OF
FINANCIAL NEED THAT IS BROADER
THAN THAT USED FOR OTHER
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS INCLUDING
THE PELL GRANT.
TODAY ABOUT HALF OF STUDENTS
HAVE THEIR FEES WAIVED IN THE
PORTION IS EVEN HIGHER FOR FULL
TIME STUDENTS.
AB NINETEEN APPROVED LAST YEAR
COULD INCREASE THESE TOTALS.
HOWEVER IS YOUR AGENDA NOTES IN
HIS PREVIOUS SPEAKERS HAVE
MENTIONED FEW OF OUR STUDENTS
RECEIVE CAL GRANTS FOR OTHER
COSTS.
AND A PREVIOUS HEARINGS I'VE
MENTIONED THE VISION FOR SUCCESS
ADOPTED BLASTER PRIOR BOARD
WHICH CALLS THIS OUT AS A CAUSE
FOR CONCERN.
FOR THAT REASON WE AGREE WITH
THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
INTENT TO MOVE AWAY FROM TUITION
COSTS AS THE PRIMARY BASIS FOR
AWARDING STATE FINANCIAL AID.
WE ALSO AGREE WITH THE EMPHASIS
ON CHANGES TO THE CAL GRANT
ELIGIBILITY RULES
AS DISCUSSED THE CURRENT RULES
LIMIT ENTITLEMENT ELIGIBILITY TO
STUDENTS WHO ENTER COLLEGE
WITHIN ONE YEAR OF HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION.
THAT'S HOW WE TRADITIONALLY
THOUGHT OF COLLEGE AGE
POPULATIONS BUT IT CERTAINLY
DOESN'T REFLECT THE TYPICAL
STUDENT AND ESPECIALLY THE
TYPICAL STUDENT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AS THE CHANCELLOR DESCRIBE YOUR
PREVIOUS HEARINGS WE SERVE A
MUCH BROADER GROUP OF STUDENTS
AND WE'RE TRYING TO DO EVEN MORE
TO REACH THOSE WERE STRANDED IN
THE WORKFORCE.
UNDER THE CURRENT STRUCTURE MOST
STUDENTS MUST COMPLETE COMPETE
FOR A LIMITED NUMBER OF AWARDS
AND THEIR CHANCES OF GETTING ONE
ARE EXCEEDINGLY LOW.
BECAUSE OF THAT STUDENTS IN OUR
COLLEGES WOULD SIMILAR LEVELS OF
FINANCIAL NEED VERY OFTEN
RECEIVE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
FINANCIAL AID.
AND TO MAKE A POINT THAT WE CAN
DISCUSS IT YA AS PART OF YOUR
LAST PANEL BECAUSE SO MANY
STUDENTS ARE CURRENTLY RISKS
ARE.
BECAUSE SO FEW OF OUR STUDENTS
CURRENTLY RECEIVE THE CAL GRANT
SIMPLY GROWING THE CAL GRANT BE
ACCESS AWARD WHICH PROVIDES
FUNDS FOR NON TUITION COSTS OR
MAKING THE CAL GRANT.
ELIGIBILITY OR CAN I RECEIVED A
CONDITION OF RECEIPT OF OTHER
FUNDS DOES NOT ADDRESS THE
AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES THAT
ARE FINANCIALLY NEEDY STUDENTS
FACE. AND SO WE WE WOULD
REITERATE THAT WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT ELIGIBILITY TO.
I DON'T WANT A QUALIFIER
EXCITEMENT ABOUT THE DIRECTION
THAT THIS REPORT TAKES BECAUSE
WE ARE VERY EXCITED BUT AS YOU
THINK ABOUT IMPLEMENTATION WE DO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE TRADE
OFFS.
WHEN WE'D RICH DETERMINE HOW TO
FUND THESE KINDS OF
RECOMMENDATIONS.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS IS AS
YOU KNOW ALREADY RECEIVE A LESS
PER STUDENT THAN THEIR PEERS
THAT THE UC AND CSU BUT
INSTITUTIONS RECEIVE LESS FOR
THOSE STUDENTS THAN ARE. THEIR
PEERS OF THE UC AND CSU AND EVEN
LESS THAN.
OR CALL EVEN LESS THAN YOU
PROVIDE TO K. TWELVE ON A PER
STUDENT BASIS
AND SO I THINK WE NEED TO BE
COGNIZANT OF.
PUTTING NEW FUNDAMENTAL
OBLIGATIONS WITHIN THE EXISTING
FUNDING LEVELS WITHIN
PROPOSITION IDIOT.
MOVING ON WE THINK THE CONCEPT
OF THE FUND FOR INNOVATION IN
FINANCIAL AID IS INTERESTING AND
WERE CONCERNED TO ABOUT OUR
STUDENTS ABILITY TO MEET THEIR
BASIC NEEDS OFTEN FEED ON
HOUSING.
LATER THIS MONTH OUR OFFICE IS
HOLDING A BASIC NEED SUMMIT WERE
COLLEGES WILL DISCUSS
IMPLEMENTATION OF STRATEGIES TO
ADDRESS STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS.
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU THERE BUT
WERE ALSO HAPPY TO REPORT BACK
ON A FUTURE A IN A FUTURE
HEARING. AND THE CENTRIFUGATION
REPORT HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR
US TO LEARN ABOUT WHAT WORKS IN
A SERIOUS WAY AND WE AGREE WITH
THAT RECOMMENDATION.
WE AGREED TO WITH THE PUSH FOR
SIMPLIFICATION IN THE REPORT
HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED TO DO MORE
ON OUR REGION INFORMATION. I
WANT A QUICKLY HIGHLIGHT THE
WORK WE DO THROUGH THE I CAN'T
AFFORD COLLEGE CAMPAIGN WHICH IS
A STATEWIDE FINANCIAL AWARENESS
INITIATIVE THAT SPONSORED BY OUR
SYSTEM. AND BEGAN IN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR WHICH WAS SHORTLY
AFTER FEES INCREASED
SO THROUGH THAT CAMPAIGN WE MAKE
SURE THAT STUDENTS OF FILM IS
NOW THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE AFFORDABLE. THAT
FINANCIALLY IS AVAILABLE YEAR
ROUND AND I COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE FINANCIALLY EXPERTS
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT THEM SO TO
THE EXTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
INTERESTED IN THINKING ABOUT NEW
APPROACHES TO OUR REACH WE HOPE
WE CAN.
IT'S ABOUT DISCUSSION TO.
WITH THAT THAT HAVE UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS OKAY THANK YOU I KNOW
THAT WAS A LOT FOR ALL OF US TO.
TO TAKE IN.
BUT WE WANT TO I HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TO GET
THE FEEDBACK FROM THAT SEGMENTS
ON ON THE REPORTS IT'S A JUST TO
REMIND THAT THE PUBLIC IN THE
COMMITTEE HERE.
THE GOAL THAT WE STARTED TWO
YEARS AGO WAS HOW CAN WE CHIU
MATIC WE EXPAND. FINANCE LADEN
CALIFORNIA TO HELP MORE
STUDENTS.
GRADUATE DEBT FREE TELLS A BIG
COMPONENT IS THAT SO MUCH OF THE
FINANCIAL AID BURDEN.
SO MUCH OF THE FINANCIAL BURDEN
ON STUDENTS IS NOT JUST TUITION
AGAIN IT'S IT'S OTHER COSTS AND.
WE KNOW THAT IT'S OUR FINANCIAL
AID STRUCTURE DOESN'T DOESN'T
COVER THAT ELEMENT SO I THINK
THAT'S A BIG PIECE OF IT.
.
ANOTHER COMPONENT IS OUR I I
THINK THERE ARE SOME PIECES THAT
ARE EXISTING FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM THAT ARE. WHETHER THEY'RE
UNFAIR DISCRIMINATORY WHAT HAVE
YOU BUT THEY JUST LEAVE PEOPLE
OUT.
THE.
YOU KNOW THE ONE YEAR THRESHOLD
FOR THE CAL GRANT I THINK IS
SOME IT SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW
SO MANY OF OUR.
I'VE OUR OF OUR INDIVIDUALS ARE
LOOKING TO GO BACK GET
THEMSELVES AND IN COLLEGE.
AFTER THEIR EIGHTEEN AND IF YOU
APPLY WHEN YOU'RE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN AS A SENIOR HIGH SCHOOL
IT'S IT'S CERTAINLY GARRETT
GUARANTEE OF COURSE WAIT A
COUPLE YEARS AND.
YOUR ODDS ARE WHAT ONE IN.
SEVENTEEN OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
AND WHEN THE SUB LIKE THAT IF
YOU APPLY FOR THE.
.
FOR THE COMPETITIVENESS THE.
THAT SEGMENT THERE WITH THE.
.
DON'T HOLE YOU CALL IT WITH THE
FAMILIES THAT DON'T HAVE THE
RIGHT.
STOOGES ANOTHER RIGHT GPA
QUALIFICATION AND THEY AND THEIR
BETWEEN FIFTEEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
BY NO MEANS WELL OFF.
I KIND OF LEFT OUT SO.
I'M REALLY KIND ABOUT THINKING
OF THOSE THINGS TO FALL SO ONE I
THINK WE STILL HAVE A GOAL IT
DRAMATICALLY EXPANDING FINANCIAL
AID TO HELP STUDENTS GRADUATE
DEBT FREE BUT THAT'S THAT.
TWO BILLION DOLLAR PRICE TAG.
AND WE WERE JUST WANNA FIND
FULLY FIND.
THE SEGMENTS TODAY TO MAKE SURE
ARE YOU SEE CS USE SYSTEMS.
CAN WORKING YOU KNOW KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON AND SO FORTH AND.
HOPEFULLY EXPAND ACCESS LITTLE
BIT BUT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE WANT TO THINK ABOUT WHAT WE
CAN DO.
FACING IT AND DOING IN PIECES SO
MAYBE I'LL I'LL START WITH YOU.
THE PIZZA IF YOU GET.
CAN TO HELP US FIGURE OUT HOW WE
COULD MANAGE THIS THIS THIS
DIFFICULT TASK RIGHT SO WHETHER
IT'S. THINGS WE CAN DO THIS YEAR
SMALLER PIECES SMALLER CHUNKS.
.
AND DEBT WHILE YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT THAT ALSO WANTED JUST A
BUT A. NOT A FOLLOWUP PIECE
EITHER YOU OR THEIR OR THE
AUTHOR OF THE REPORT TO. MAYBE
GIVE US A MENU OF OF DOLLAR
AMOUNTS FOR SOME OF THESE PIECES
SO IT WASN'T EASILY.
AVAILABLE IT CAN THE REPORT WE
HAVE BEFORE US TODAY.
JOINING.
SO I'M WHAT WE PROPOSE TODAY AS
THE THREE CERTAIN COMPONENTS
THAT WE THOUGHT WOULD BE HELPFUL
BUT. YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
YOU KNOW OF THE INNOVATION FIND
WOULD BE WHATEVER THE
LEGISLATURE OF FELT THAT WAS.
IMPORTANCE OF IN TERMS OF AN
AMOUNT IF WE WANTED TO TEST SOME
OF THESE THEORIES OUT AND
UNIVERSITIES THE. OF INCREASING
THE ACCESS AWARD OBVIOUSLY IF
YOU INTEREST KRISTA TO EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED FOR INSTANCE WOULD BE
THIRTY ONE MILLION IF YOU
INCREASED IT TO TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED IT WOULD BE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE ABOUT A
HUNDRED SIXTY TWO I'M. SORRY IT
WOULD BE.
.
TO TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE MILLION TO
THREE THOUSAND AND BE TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT MILLION SO
AND WE HAVE THAT FOR EACH OF THE
STAGES RIGHT NOW AND THAT'S JUST
A THREE THOUSAND BUT IF WE WERE
TO GO TO SIX THOUSAND. WE HAVE
THOSE COSTS AS WELL.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT THE VALUE OF THE BE ACCESS
AWARD IS A LOT OF HIS TUNES ARE
GRADUATING IN TIME BECAUSE THEY
FEEL THE NEED TO HAVE TO WORK
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T MAKE ENDS
MEET BE ABLE TO STUDY FULL TIME.
IT SO I WE DO BELIEVE THAT.
WHOLEHEARTEDLY THAT INCREASINGLY
ACTS WORDS VERY IMPORTANT
OBVIOUSLY ITEM CAN DEBATE
WHETHER OR NOT. THE OUTREACH
COMPONENT OF THEM IS ESSENTIAL
BUT WE WE SERVE STUDENTS WHILE
BEFORE THEY EVEN APPLY TO
COLLEGE WHO WERE SERVING
STUDENTS.
WHILE THEY'RE STILL IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND THEIR FAMILIES IN
FACT WE HAVE A COUPLE OUTREACH
PROGRAMS THAT KELSO ABOUT REPOSE
PROGRAM IN THE CASH BECAUSE IT
YOU'RE PRETTY FAMILIAR WITH AS
WELL SO.
YOU KNOW WE THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT HOWEVER IF.
IF THE LEGISLATURE'S INTERESTED
IN SIR FOR INSTANCE REMOVING THE
DOUGHNUT HOLE AYE BUT WE BELIEVE
IN WE CAN GET YOU THESE COST
ESTIMATES OF COURSE IN THE DON'T
A WHOLE MEANS. OF FOR A FAMILY
COULD EXCITE ME EXPLAIN WHAT
THAT IS. SO FOR A FAMILY OF FOUR
THAT MAKES BETWEEN ZERO AND A
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IF THE STUDENT HAS A TWO POINT
OH GPA YOU'RE GOOD TO GO TO CAL
GRANT.
IF A FAMILY OF FOUR THE MIX
BETWEEN ZERO AND A HUNDRED
THOUSAND.
OKAY.
AND.
MAKES THREE POINT HAS A THREE
POINT EIGHT GPA THEY ALSO GET A
CAL GRANT.
FOR THE STUDENT.
OF THE IS AT FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
A FIFTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND AS A TWO POINT NINE GPA THEY
GET NOTHING.
NOTHING.
BECAUSE THERE'S THE THE THE TO
POINT OUT THREE POINT NOW IS
SORT OF THE. OF THE BASIS FOR
THE INCREASING OF THE WHAT THE
HOUSEHOLD COULD BANKRATE WE
KNOW.
THAT IT UC BERKELEY FOR INSTANCE
TO ATTEND ACOSTA ATTENDANCES
WHAT THIRTY TO THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND.
DEPENDING ON LIVING SITUATION
AND SO EVEN FOR A FAMILY MAKING
SEVENTY OR EIGHTY THOUSAND THEY
COULDN'T AFFORD SENDING THEIR
STUDENTS OF UC BERKELEY WITHOUT
SOME SORT OF GRANT IT MIND YOU
THEY MIGHT GET. AND SOME
INSTITUTIONAL AID LOANS AND.
WHAT HAVE YOU BUT IT WOULD BE
EXORBITANT SO THERE'S THAT
DOUGHNUT HOLE AND THAT'S WORTH
AND I'M LOOKING BACK AT DAVID?
FIFTY MILLION OR SO.
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF FIFTY
MILLION TO CLOSE THAT DOUGHNUT
HOLES WHAT WE CALL IF WE WERE TO
ELIMINATE NOW WE KNOW THAT CSU
AND YOU SEE. THE PRETTY
COMPETITIVE BUT WHAT'S WE WE IN
THE PASSPORT SAVING PURPOSES WE
IMPLEMENTED AT GPA REQUIREMENT
WE KNOW HOW COMPETITIVE UC AND
CSU IS SHOULD WE NOT LEAVE.
THAT TO THE UNIVERSITY IF THERE
THE STUDENT IS OF WORTHY ENOUGH
TO GO RECEIVE ADMITTANCE TO A
CSU THEN WE SHOULD. PROVIDE THEM
THE FINANCIALLY THEY NEED TO GO
RIGHT SO THAT'S ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF COURSE.
IN THE REPORT AS WELL AND THEN
THE ONE YEAR OUT SITUATION SO WE
ARE VERY GENEROUS IN CALIFORNIA
AND IF WE. OF WE PROVIDE EVERY
HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR WITH A TWO
POINT OH GPA AND ABILITY TO
RECEIVE FINANCIALLY THAT'S
CALLED AN ENTITLEMENT BUT IF YOU
WAIT A YEAR AND A DAY AFTER
GRADUATION DECIDE TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL AND MANY STUDENTS DO. YOU
ARE NO LONGER ON THE ENTITLEMENT
LIST THERE IS A LIST OF ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS FOR TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
AWARDS.
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY FOR ANYONE
ABOVE THE ENTITLEMENT AN OLDER
THAN.
SORT OF AND IF THAT DIDN'T GET
IN RIGHT AWAY THAT MADE A
DIFFERENT DECISION UP OR
COULDN'T NEEDED TO WORKER YOU
KNOW SOMETHING LIKE THAT SO. SO
WE REALLY DO NEED TO ADDRESS
THAT AS WELL.
YOU KNOW.
SO THOSE TWO COMPONENTS RIGHT
THERE.
WOULD HELP CLOSE SOME GAPS.
AND WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO PUT
SOME A ESTIMATES TOGETHER FOR
YOU IN TERMS OF WHAT THAT WOULD
COST ANOTHER IF YOU WANTED TO
ADD ANYTHING.
RETIREMENT UMBEL IN TERMS OF
SORT OF A MENU OF OF ITEMS.
.
CERTAINLY THE.
THAT.
THAT THE CHEAPEST THING THAT YOU
COULD DO THAT WOULD HAVE THE
BIGGEST IMPACT WOULD BE SOME OF
THE EARLY INFORMATION KINDS OF
EFFORTS WHICH.
YOU KNOW MAYBE A FEW MILLION
DOLLARS IT'S NOT HERE AND NOT A
HUGE HUGE INVESTMENT BUT THE
KIND OF THING WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE. IS NOT JUST SOME
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE FOR OUTREACH.
BUT A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
SYSTEMIC APPROACH TO PROVIDING
INFORMATION TO FAMILIES THAT THE
HIGH SCHOOL FAMILIES TO HIGH
SCHOOL FAMILIES EAT SANTO UNTIL
ADULTS WHO MIGHT BE INTERESTED
IN GOING AND IN GOING TO COLLEGE
YOU MAYBE. DON'T REALIZE WHAT
THEY'RE WHAT THEIR OPTIONS ARE
SO FOR EXAMPLE.
BIT IN THE REPORT THERE'S
ACTUALLY ALREADY.
AUTHORITY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STOOD NAY COMMISSION TO WORK
WITH THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AND
GET INFORMATION WITH SOME
TWEAKING OF THAT.
EXISTING AUTHORITY.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE NAY
COMMISSION COULD HAVE A WEBSITE
WHERE FAMILY COULD GO ON AND
SAY.
PLEASE ACCESS MY NAME FOR THE
INCOME INFORMATION THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE GOVERNMENT
ALREADY HAS AND PROVIDE ME WITH
SOME ESTIMATES FOR MY CHILD OR
ME TO GO TO COLLEGE AND THOSE
ESTIMATES COULD PROVIDE
COMPARATIVE EXAMPLES BASED ON
THEIR ACTUAL FINANCIAL
SITUATION.
FOR CS YOU YOU SEE LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE MAYBE A
PRIVATE COLLEGE.
THAT'S KIND OF INFORMATION THAT
IF IF YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING
YOU CAN NOW LIKE GO TO A CAN TO
A ANY COLLEGES WEBSITE AND GO IN
AND PLUG IN A BOMB TO BUNCH OF
INFORMATION AND GET THAT. AND
AND AND GET AN ESTIMATE BACK BUT
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE
A TO EVEN KNOW THAT THEY CAN DO
THAT OR BE. TO DO THAT ON
MULTIPLE COLLEGE WEBSITES AND
GET IN AND GET SOMETHING THAT IS
COMPARATIVE.
NOBODY DOES IT.
BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
CALIFORNIA'S DIDN'T EIGHT
COMMISSION AND.
COULD NOT COULD IMPLEMENT.
BASED ON DATA SYSTEMS THAT ARE
OUT THAT OUT THERE NOW WHITE
WOULD KNOW THOUGH THAT THEY THE
GRANT DELIVERY SYSTEM
DEVELOPMENT THAT THAT IS ALSO
PART OF THE BUDGET ISN'T IS
IMPORTANT ALL OF THAT. BUT THAT.
THAT KIND OF A MOVE IS TOTALLY
DOABLE WE ALSO SUGGEST THAT.
RATHER THAN TRYING TO RATHER
THAN A BIG INFORMATION CAMPAIGN
OR IN ADDITION TO AN INFORMATION
CAMPAIGN TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
GET ACCESS TO SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. YUKI IT COULD EVEN HAVE
SOMETHING LIKE A CHECK BOX ON
THE CALIFORNIA STATE INCOME TAX
FORM THAT SAYS. YES PLEASE USE
MY INFORMATION TO GET ME.
GET ME AT COLLEGE.
AFFORDABILITY.
COMPARISON SOMETHING SO THAT IT
IS A SYSTEMIC. KIND OF.
KIND OF APPROACH IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR CEASE ACTIVE THEN ALSO HAVE
PEOPLE WHO CAN ANSWER QUESTIONS
WHEN QUESTIONS COME UP.
BUT CERTAINLY THE THE KIND OF
INFORMATION AND OUTREACH
EFFORTS.
ARE ARE THE LOWEST COST
I WOULD SAY IN ON THIS MENU THAT
IF THERE IS.
WHAT I GUESS THE STATE CALLS
ONE TIME MONEY OUT THERE IF
THERE'S SOMEONE TIME MONEY?
AND INNOVATION FUND IS A GOOD
PLACE TO.
TO PUT THAT WOULD BE GREAT IF
IT WAS MULTI YEAR BUT YOU COULD
DO SOME REALLY USE FALL.
TESTS OF EFFORTS WITH.
WITH INNOVATION FUND.
.
THE.
S. C. SACK HAS PROVIDED YOU
WITH KIND OF A RANGE OF OPTIONS
ON THE CAL GRANT BE ACCESS AWARD
AREA SO FOR TALKING ESPECIALLY
FOR TALKING IMPOSSIBLE MULTIPLE
YEARS. INCREASING THE CAL GRANT.
BE THERE'S A RANGE THAT COULD BE
TAKEN THERE.
AND THEN YOU KNOW AS IT GOES UP
IF YOU WANT TO ACTUALLY DO A
CONSOLIDATION THIS WOULD BELIKE
FOR THE NEXT YEAR.
OUR ESTIMATE IF THAT COULD BE
DONE.
THE THAT THE BUT YOU NEED TO
MAKE SURE IS THAT ESPECIALLY CSU
IS MADE.
IS MADE WHOLE IF YOU IMPLEMENT
IT AND DON'T ADEQUATELY FUNDED
ALICE AS WAS INDICATED YOU COULD
ACTUALLY END UP IN A SITUATION
WHERE SOME PEOPLE LOSE OUT WE
DON'T WANT WE WANTED THIS TO BE
AN AD SITUATION.
AND NOT A SUBTRACTION SO I'D AT
OUR ESTIMATE WAS A COUPLE OF
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR CS
YOU AND THAT SITUATION.
I'M NEITHER ASTERISK THERE.
ONE OF THE MOST
PRISING THINGS WE FOUND WAS HOW
LITTLE DATA SEE SACK HAS OTHERS
HAVE ENORMOUS AMOUNTS OF DATA.
BUT ACTUALLY SEES THAT DOESN'T
KNOW. WHICH WHO ENROLLED OR
DIDN'T IN WHICH I HAVE WATCHED
IT WHAT INSTITUTIONS THEY GOT A
CAL GRANT THEY KNOW THEY'RE
GETTING A CAR GOING TO GO TO
THAT PARTICULAR INSTITUTION. BUT
THE ABILITY TO DO THINGS LIKE
COST ESTIMATES.
USING THE DATA THAT'S AVAILABLE
TO SEE SACCHI IS IS A VERY.
LIMITED.
BUILDING THAT AND OVER TIME
WILL BE VERY USEFUL AND SORT OF
ANALYZING WHERE WE ARE GAPS ARE.
GOING FORWARD AND AS YOU SAID
THAT THAT IT'S. ADDRESSING DEBT
IS A TWO BILLION DOLLAR ISSUE.
AN IMPORTANT PLACE TO START IS
WITH MORE FUNDS FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
IN AT EITHER A CONSOLIDATED OR
AT LEAST TO START A CAL GRANT BE
KIND OF A PROJECT.
AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT LATER
BUT THE COMMUNICABLE SPACES GOT
ONLY GENERAL FUND BUT WE COULD
DISCUSS THAT UNDER PROPAGANDHI
EIGHT. YOU KNOW WE HAD I THINK
IT MIGHT. YEARS PLAYER LAST YEAR
A YEAR BEFORE THE FIRST YEAR AND
HAD A DEBATE ABOUT FINANCIAL AID
WERE LOOKING ABOUT TO BE WANT
TO.
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE.
AWARDS OR EXPAND OR INCREASE
THE AWARD AMOUNT AND SO.
WE AT THINK WE ASK IF YOU PASSED
YOU MAY BE IN HYPOTHETICAL BE
ONLY HAD. FIFTY MILLION BUCKS
WHICH I WOULD YOU CHOOSE A
PRIMARY GUY I CAN DO THAT.
SO IT JUST COMES DOWN TO THE
SAME ISSUE AGAIN YOU KNOW. THE
DOUGHNUT HOLE VERSUS THE ACCESO
WORKS AT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
MISSED OUT ON THE DON'T HOLE ARE
THEY NOT GOING TO COLLEGE WHAT
HAPPENS TO THEM.
IF THERE.
DO THEY GO TO THAT SEE IS YOU
AND TRY TO GET THAT SAGA AWARD
TO TO PAY FOR IT OR AT THE YOU
SEE. YOU IN OTHER WORDS.
WHICH WANTED WHICH PIECES GIVES
US THE BIGGEST.
BANG FOR OUR BUCK
AS FAR AS.
HELPING EXPAND
COLLEGE ACCESS
BUT CERTAIN THE AND THEY DO WHAT
I DID FIND A RECENTLY THAT IF IF
A STUDENT DOESN'T RECEIVE A CAL
GRANT VOTE SAAB THEY DO RECEIVE
A STUDENT AT UNIVERSITY. OF
STATE UNIVERSITY GRANT FROM THE.
CSU SYSTEM AND I'M SURE THAT
IT'S SIMILAR FOR A UC SYSTEM IN
TERMS OF THAT. DOUGHNUT HOLE
WHAT AND THAT THAT COVERS TO
WISHIN.
BUT THE COST OF ATTENDANCE IS
STILL AN ISSUE. RIGHT AND SO
MANY OF THOSE THINGS HAVE TO
TAKE ADDITIONAL LOANS TO MAKE
ENDS MEET RIGHT.
.
YOU KNOW SO SO FAT STUDENT WOULD
HAVE GOTTEN THE CAL GRANT. THEY
WOULD HAVE GOTTEN THE SAGER THE
UC AWARD TO PAY TO HELP PAY FOR
THEIR NON TUITION AND NOW THEY
DON'T GET BACK THAT JUST PAYS
FOR TUITION SO YOU'RE SAYING.
I THINK SO BUT THEY COULD
PROBABLY ANSWER THAT BETTER THAN
I.
DON'T HAVE THE UNIVERSITIES
AFFECTED WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS WE
STILL TRYING TO FILL THAT GAP TO
KEEP THAT WON'T WORK MANAGEABLE
SO WITH THE STUDENT DOESN'T
RECEIVE THE CAL GRANT. THE END
UP GETTING THE SAME AMOUNT OF
GRANT TOTAL THAT THEY WOULD GET
WE WOULD JUST SHIFT SOURCES TO
TRY TO KEEP THAT CONSISTENT
WON'T WORK IN ALL CASES. NOW TO
THE EXTENT THAT THERE IS A DON'T
HOLD THAT MEANS THERE'S LESS
GRANT MONEY UNIVERSITY WIDE
AVAILABLE AND THAT'S ALL GRANT
TO SIT ALL GRANT RECIPIENTS. ARE
BORROWING WORKING A LITTLE BIT
MORE SO SORT AFFECTS ALL
STUDENTS THE EFFECTIVELY SPREAD
ACROSS THE SCREEN. AS OPPOSED TO
BEING ISOLATED TO THOSE STUDENTS
WHO AFFECTED DIRECTLY BY THE
DOUGHNUT HOLE.
SO BACK THEY QUESTIONS VIRUS IF
IF WE HAD TO CHOOSE WE HAD WHICH
ONE IS IS IS MORE
VALUABLE. TODAY.
CHAVEZ I THINK IT INCREASE IN
BODY AS I IT'S REALLY HARD TO
SAY I MEAN I THINK AND. I THINK
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THE COST OF ATTENDANCE.
WE ABSOLUTE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THE COST WITH TENANTS AND
RIGHT NOW THE WAY WE DO THAT IS
THROUGH THE BE ACCESO WAR.
SONY TO REALLY CONSIDER AND
THINK ABOUT IT YOU KNOW WHAT
WITH HOW WE'RE SETTING UP
STUDENTS BASICALLY YES YOU CAN
GET IN AND HERE'S A LITTLE MONEY
FOR TUITION BUT. GOOD LUCK WITH
THE REST OF IT.
AND WE'RE SEEING THAT PLAY OUT
THROUGH HOUSING FOOD INSECURITY
WE'RE SEEING THAT PLAY OUT
THROUGH NOT GRADUATING BE HAVING
TO WORK A LOT MORE SO. YOU KNOW
I'M OUR CHAIRS HERE TOO SO WE
HAVEN'T HAD THAT STIRRED DEBATE
AMONGST OUR COMMISSIONERS OR
ANYTHING BUT. YOU KNOW I THINK
WE REALLY I THINK THE THE
CLOSING THE DOUGHNUT HOLE IN THE
GPA IS REALLY MORE OF A
COMMUNICATIONS A STREAMLINING.
OF AND IT DOESN'T COST A LOT A
IN IT BEING ABLE TO SAY LOOK IF
YOU MAKE BETWEEN A HUNDRED AND
MEAL BRIDGING THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP IN INCLUDING. LET'S
JUST SAY WE PAINT BUT MAKE
BETWEEN A HUNDRED AND.
A HUNDRED GO BETWEEN ZERO ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND YOU WILL
GET A CALL GOING TOWARD SOME
SNOW IN ORDER TO PAY HELP PAY
FOR TUITION IT MEANS BEING ABLE
TO COMMUNICATE THAT RIGHT NOW.
USE A WILL YOU MAKE IT IN A OR
B. OR MAYBE A SEPA SI IS WORTH
LESS YOU KNOW THIS IS THE CITY'S
STUDENTS FOR. CHAVEZ AND OPAL
THIS IS THAT WE WORRIED LESS
THEN OF ME YOU KNOW A STUDENT
THAT'S JUST GOING TO COMMITTEE
BECAUSE TO GO FOR AN A A DEGREE
FOR INSTANCE AND SO THERE'S
JUST.
THESE SORT OF. UNEXPLAINED SORT
OF REASONS FOR WHY A STUDENT YOU
KNOW CITY STUDENTS OR FOR SOME
REASON GETS A THOUSAND DOLLARS
VERSUS THE SIXTEEN HUNDRED. FOR
THE SAME SORT OF YOU KNOW OF
BEING ABLE TO AFFORD THE DID A
DIFFERENT AGREE THAT'S TRYING TO
ATTAIN SO AND THE MIDDLE CLASS
STUDENT GETS UP. A PITTANCE BUT
YOU KNOW IF THEY'RE AT THE
HIGHER AND.
AND IT'S A LAST DOLLAR AND THEY
GET LIKE TOWARDS THE END SO. I
YOU KNOW PART OF THE REASON THAT
WE WENT INTO WANTED TO
CONSOLIDATE AND STREAMLINES THE
PALPITA COMMUNICATE WHAT A
FAMILY COULD GET.
A AND AFFORD AND WHAT THEY
SHOULD BE STAVING FOR RIGHT OF
BUT THE SAME TIME.
KEEPING TO TUITION AND FEES IS
NOT HELPING.
STUDENTS AND YOU KNOW MAKE IT
THROUGH THEIR COLLEGE EXPERIENCE
SUCCESSFULLY SO.
I'M IN A PUNT OVER TOWARD
CHERISHES ANYTHING ELSE YOU WANT
TO ADD.
YOU KNOW IT'S A REALLY HARD
QUESTION AND I THINK IF I WERE.
YOU KNOW IF IF THE COMMISSION
WERE DISCUSSING AT MY WORD WE
WERE TO PUT THAT QUESTION IN
FRONT OF THEM THEY'D PROBABLY
LOOK AT ME AND SAY IT'S LIKE.
CHOOSING BETWEEN WHICH OF YOUR
TWO CHILDREN IS YOUR FAVORITE.
RIGHT ARM ANY AT THE END OF THE
DAY WE BOTH WANT TO ENSURE THAT
WE GUARANTEE ACCESS IN THAT WE
HAVE AS MANY STUDENTS BE ABLE TO
GET INTO COLLEGE AND GO TO
COLLEGE AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE STUDENTS WHO WERE
THERE. ARE ACTUALLY SUPPLIED
WITH ADEQUATE RESOURCES SO
THEY'RE NOT LIVING IN THEIR CARS
AND SO THEY'RE NOT GOING TO FOOD
PANTRIES AND SO THAT. THEY HAVE
ACTUALLY THE RESOURCES SO THAT
THEY CAN ACTUALLY STUDY AND
MOVED THROUGH IN A TIMELY WAY.
AND THERE'S SOME ARGUMENT TO BE
MADE THAT THE BARRIERS THAT
STUDENTS EXPERIENCE ONCE THEY'RE
ACTUALLY IN COLLEGE.
COULD BE SLOWING THEM DOWN SO
THAT THEY'RE NOT ACTUALLY
GETTING THROUGH IN ITS TIMELY
FASHION AND THEN THAT IS ACOSTA
NOT JUST THE INSTITUTIONS NOT
JUST IT BUT ALSO TO THE STATE.
SO I DON'T KNOW THAT AND YOU
KNOW WE CAN MAKE A DECISION
BETWEEN YOU KNOW THAT THE
STUDENTS WITH THE DONOR WHOLE
VERSES YOU KNOW GIVING A LITTLE
BIT MORE.
I THINK IT'S YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THEY'RE BOTH IMPORTANT
PRIORITIES BOTH FOR THIS FOR
THAT FOR OF THE INSTITUTIONS FOR
STUDENTS FOR FAMILIES AND FOR
THE STATE.
JEFF JARVIS.
WHY LOOK AT FOUR DID THIS
DISCUSSION I THINK IT'S A? VERY
GOOD.
TAKEN ABACK AS WE STARTED THIS
AS YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN ARE SIX
YEARS.
WELL WAS FIVE YEARS AGO WE'RE
LOOKING AT.
DEBT FREE COLLEGE FOR STUDENTS.
YOUNG WE LOOKED THE COSTA
COLLEGE WELL LIKE DEAD FRAME
THIS IN SOME OF THE HEARING YOU
HAD EARLIER.
ONE OF THE FIRST OBJECTIVES WE
ESTABLISH.
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO WAS TO
MAKE THE COLLEGES MORE EFFECTIVE
IN.
TRY TO GET STUDENTS WHO ARE
TAKEN SIX AND SEVEN YEARS TO GET
OUT OF COLLEGE TO GET ON FOR
YEARS.
AND THAT WAS THE ISSUE WAS THE
TRANSFER RATE FROM COMMUNITY
COLLEGES DESY ISSUES. THAT THE
C. ISSUES OF RECOGNIZE THE
CLASSES TAKEN THAT OTHERS SEE
ISSUES WOULD SAY OH OUR ENGLISH
CLASS BETTER YOURS SO YOU HAVE
TO TAKE IT OVER AGAIN.
SO'S WE START LOOKING ALL
EFFICIENCIES AND.
AND I'M HAPPY TO SAY I THINK
WE'D LIKE LAST REFORM WOULD
PROBABLY CUT A YEAR OFF WHO SAID
A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
THE OTHER THING WE DID WAS WE
RECOGNIZE THAT. MANY STUDENTS
GOING TO COLLEGE WILL PREPARE
FOR COLLEGE.
IT IS BECAUSE LIKE CHILDREN
STUDENTS HAD TO TAKE REMEDIAL
CLASSES WHICH TOOK A MORE TIME
AT THE. KEY MANY COLLEGES ARE
SEE ISSUES BUT DIDN'T ALLOW THEM
TO.
YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW THAT IT DISCUSS MORE
MONEY WHY THEY'RE THERE.
AND SO DO ELSIE HAVE EL CAP.
ALWAYS SEEN THEM BETTER RESULTS
DENIES HAPPY TO SAY THE OTHER
DAY WE HAD A HEARING.
THE PRESS NEVER WRITES ABOUT
THEY THINK WE CALIFORNIA FORTY
NIGHTS IN THE NATION AS YOU AND
I THINK LAST WEEK UP ABOUT FORTY
ONE.
PEOPLE'S OUR THIRTY NINE WHICH
ISN'T GREAT BUT IT'S BETTER THAN
FORTY NINE SO I THINK ARE WE
GOING THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
AND THEN WE LOOKED AT THE ISSUE
ASSISTANCE FAMILIES A TRUE
TALKING ABOUT NOW.
.
I'VE READ YOUR REPORT IN FACT I
JUST LOOK AT THE WEBSITE AGAIN I
GUESS.
YOU ADOPTED THIS THING FOR AT
THESE
ON ACCORDING TO YOUR CENTER
FOUNDATION ARTICLE. AND I BROKE
INTO THREE AREAS THE CAL GRANT
INNOVATION AND. EARLIER
INFORMATION.
I WAS INTRIGUED.
BY WHAT MISTER CHAIRMAN SAID.
AND I WONDER IF YOU WILL BUT.
CLARIFY FOR ME.
YOU SAID THAT EVERY STUDENT.
MY EVERY EVERY PERSON EVERY
YOUNG PERSON IN CALIFORNIA. IS
COLLEGE POTENTIAL GUY MISCARRY
OR DID YOU SAY THAT ARE NOW I
THINK WE NEED TO THINK OF EVERY
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AS A
POTENTIAL COLLEGE STUDENTS
SOMEONE WHO MIGHT GO TO COLLEGE.
IF THEY KNEW WHAT OPTIONS WERE
AVAILABLE TO THEM AND HOW THEY
COULD AFFORD IT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS ON
THAT IN I THINK. NOT EVERY STE
INDIVIDUAL WANTS TO GO TO
COLLEGE ABSOLUTELY IN THERE'S
LITTLE AND I THINK THAT'S FOR.
WHEN TO COMMUNICATE LA JUST AS A
LOT OF DISCUSSION ON THE GRID
TECHNOLOGY OCCASION. AND WHERE
PARTNER WITH BUSINESSES AND
PEOPLE
STARTING ACTUALLY IN THE HIGH
SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES TO GO INTO.
DIFFERENT CAREERS WE HAVE A
LARGE NEED OF THEM SAW SELECT.
AND THEN ELECTRICAL FIELD SINCE
WE'RE GOING ELECTRIFY THE GRADE
CALLED ME RUNOFF ELECTED CARS IN
A FEW YEARS. SO WE NEED
ELECTRICITY.
ABSOLUTELY SO WE DON'T NEED
FRENCH LITERATURE MAJORS SO WE
ELECT PRESIDENTS YEAH.
IF I A CAP I CAN JUST YEAH SO I
AND AND.
BY SAYING THAT EVERY EVERY
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT IS A
POTENTIAL COLLEGE STUDENTS I AM
NEITHER SAYING THAT EVERYONE
SHOULD GO TO COLLEGE AND WHEN I
SAY COLLEGE I ACTUALLY MEAN
INCLUDING.
CAREER TECHNICAL KINDS OF
PROGRAMS ELECTRICITY AND WELDING
AT OTHER KINDS OF THINGS AND TOO
MANY CALIFORNIANS DON'T REALIZE
THAT THOSE OPTIONS FOR TRAINING
ARE AVAILABLE. TO THEM.
AND.
AND THEY NEED TO KNOW THAT
THAT'S AVAILABLE TO THEM THAT
IT'S NOT JUST THE OTHER DAY THAT
THERE ARE PROGRAMS THAT THEY GO
TO THAT IT NOT ABOUT TAKING MORE
HISTORY CLASSES YOUR LITERATURE.
LITERATURE CLASSES SO THAT THE
INFORMATION THAT STUDENTS THAT
PROTEST THESE POTENTIAL STUDENTS
SHOULD GET.
NEEDS TO INCLUDE THOSE KINDS OF
OPTIONS
VERY FEW HUNDRED PERCENT AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING I THINK.
THE COMMUNICABLE GEN I'M HAPPY
TO SAY A LOT OF THE TRADE UNIONS
ARE PART IN WITH US. FOR THOSE
APPRENTICESHIPS AND ADJOURNMENTS
JOB AND I THINK IT'S WONDERFUL.
THE. YOU MAY KNOW THE COMMENT
THAT YOU SAID.
OF REGARDLESS A GPA.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT
MORE SURE SO I'M.
WE HEARD FROM A LOT OF.
ASK FOLKS IN K. TWELVE AND THE
COLLEGES AND THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT HATE COMMISSION ABOUT A
LOT OF EFFORTS TO MATCH DATA ON
GPAS BECAUSE OF THE GPA
REQUIREMENTS AND THE CAL GRANT
AND IT SEEMED THAT ULTIMATELY.
THOSE WERE NOT ALL OF THAT
EFFORT WAS NOT ACTUALLY
RESULTING AND ANY.
IMPROVEMENT UP FOR THE.
FOR THE SYSTEM OVERALL BECAUSE
UC AND CSU IN ADMITTING STUDENTS
IN THE FIRST PLACE ARE LOOKING
AT.
AT GPAS AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY
LOOKING AT GPAS AN A MORE ROBUST
AND SOPHISTICATED WAY THEN YOU
KNOW THEY'LL PAY TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION QUESTIONS OF WHAT
COURSES ARE AVAILABLE AT THE
SCHOOLS AND ARE THEY TAKING A
PEE AND I'D BE. AND SO IT SEEMED
ULTIMATELY THAT THE GPA
REQUIREMENTS.
ARE CREATING MORE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROBLEMS
THEN THEY ARE WORTH.
BECAUSE WE HAVE OTHER SYSTEMS
IN PLACE ON THE ADMISSION SIDE
AND ON THE.
STATUS ON THE AND AND IN TERMS
OF WHETHER STUDENTS ARE.
ARE BAD PROGRESSING PUTS ON A
SATISFACTORY ACADEMIC PROGRESS
FOR EXAMPLE AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
SO YOU WOULDN'T WANT SOMEBODY
WHO'S.
EIGHT YEARS OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL
WHO DECIDES TO GO TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND LIKE
THEY'VE TOTALLY TURN THEIR LIFE
AROUND AND SUDDENLY THERE HIGH
SCHOOL GPA OF PREVENTINGTHEM
FROM GETTING.
FINANCIAL AID INSTEAD THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THEY COME THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE THAT PLACEMENT
TASTES PLOT TESTS PUT THEM WHERE
WHERE THEY NEED TO BE. AND THE
QUESTION SHOULD BE ARE THEY
MAKING PROGRESS AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND THAT THOSE SYSTEMS
THAT ARE IN PLACE ARE BETTER
THAN THAT SORT OF THE STRICT CUT
OFF THAT WE GOT IN THE STATUTE
RIGHT NOW.
I'M GLAD YOU CLARIFIED THAT
BECAUSE I'M TALKING MANY.
.
YOU SEE PRESIDENT SOON SEE
ISSUES THEY ARE A LOOK AT THE
WHOLE STUDENT THEY'RE NOT THEIR
LOOK AND ACT DAM WE SOCIALIZE
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'VE GONE
THROUGH SO. I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THE GPAS YOU BECAUSE IF
YOU LOOK AT THE LOG CHART TO BE
PASSED OUT HERE.
THAT WAS DONE BY THE UC'S.
YOU KNOW JUST RANSOM SULFUR GPA
INFLUENCED
SO.
THIS IS SO HERE'S HERE'S WHY
LEGIT TO.
WHERE I'M GOING WITH THIS NOW?
?
I BELIEVE THE COW GRASS SEED TO
BE LOOKED AT BUT I'M WONDERING.
HOW WE TRYING TO DESIGN?
THEY FUNDING SYSTEM.
THAT SUPPORTS THREE DIFFERENT.
EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENTS.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THE WONDERFUL JOB WE TALKED
ABOUT TRADES AND GOING IN AND.
MAYBE THEY ARE TRANSFERRING OUT
TO CSU UC VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE
MORE FROM OUR.
BEING RETRAIN FOR SKILLS IN
JOBS.
THE UC'S I DON'T THINK WE GIVE
ENOUGH CREDIT ON. REALLY THEIR
ECONOMIC INNOVATION HUBS FOR
REGIONS IN THE STATE.
AND YOU LOOK AT WITH AN UC'S.
IN I BRAG ABOUT ARE YOU SEE THE
TOP TEN UNIVERSITIES.
IN THE NATION YOU CAN LOOK AT
THERE'S ALWAYS TWO OR THREE OF
OUR UC'S AND. SO WHEN PEOPLE SAY
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA'S GOING DOWN
A SINKHOLE AND AGAIN I DON'T
KNOW UC'S LOOK PRETTY GOOD TO
ME.
AND THEN THE C. S. USE.
ARE.
TREMENDOUS.
ECONOMIC.
PDAS AND GOING.
THEY'VE GOT SUCH A GREAT JOB TO
DEVELOP THE ECONOMY OF NORTH
COUNTY SAN DIEGO.
SO BUT THEY THEY'RE DIFFERENT
PEOPLE.
NOT LIKE A BETTER PEOPLE IT'S
DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
SO THEY ALL HAVE AN IMPORTANT
ROLE.
BACK TO MY QUESTION ARE WE
DEVELOPING.
FUNDING SYSTEM A TRY TO.
GET TOGETHER FUNNY SYSTEM THAT'S
ACTUALLY WORK IN THREE DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENTS.
AND JUSTICE LA SLASH THOUGHT I
THINK THIS YEAR'S YOU TOUCHED ON
IT.
IT WASN'T LAST WEEK THERE IN
HERE ASKING FOR A HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLAR PLUS.
IN A LOT OF US SAID HEY WE'RE
ALL ABOARD.
.
WOULD TO SEE ISSUES LIKE I SAID
BACK OFF THAT HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE MILLION PLUS UP. TO BEEF
WHAT'S THE TERM WE USE IN FULLY
FUNDED SEE ISSUES.
AT AT THE EXPENSE OF THIS.
AND I WOULD THINK.
PROBABLY NOT.
AND SO IT'S ACCURATE SURPRISE
WHEN I'M DOWN DUE TO MOVE AHEAD
NO COVERAGE YOU'RE YOU'RE BETTER
POLITICIAN THAN I AM SO THE.
SO I I THINK WE. I LIKED A
DISCUSSION OF THE GETS GO BUT I
I'M JUST TRYING TO BRING SOME
ROUTE REALITY.
WE NOTICED WE HAD A PROBLEM
WITH.
COSTA DEBT FOR EDUCATION FOR
CHILDREN WAS TOO MUCH.
WE HAD TO DO SOMETHING.
WE LOOKED EFFICIENCIES OF THE
SCHOOLS WE LOOKED AT PREPARING A
BETTER STUDENTS AND I'M VERY
PROUD OF ALL AYE TEACHES AYE.
KATIE TWELVE AN EARLY EDUCATION
WHAT MR MCCARTY AND I'VE BEEN
PUSHIN FOR YEARS WE DO A LOT OF
GOOD STUFF LIKE THAT AND I'M
JUST.
WONDERING IF.
THERE'S SOME REALITY THIS WHEN
YOU LOOK AT ON ONE FUNDED SYSTEM
FOR THREE DIFFERENT WORLDS.
CERTIFICATE IS QUICKLY ANSWERS
SO LET'S SAY YOU TAKE US TO
OUTSIDE OF TRIPLETS.
THAT ARE GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL
AND ONE WAS TO GO TO YOU SEE
ONCE ONCE YOU GO TO SEE AS SOON
Y. WANTS TO GO TO COMEY BECAUSE
THE ONE THE ONCE OVER THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE WANTS TO GO ON
TO A CD TRACK.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ARGUE HERE
IS THAT ALL THREE OF THOSE COME
FROM A VERY LOW INCOME FAMILY?
SO REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY GO
TO OCS YOU USE YOUR COMEY
COLLEGE THE TUITION IS LIKELY
GOING TO BE PAID. RIGHT.
IN SOME WAY GOING TO BE FINANCED
THEIR COST OF ATTENDANCE.
MAY NOT BE FINANCE IN THE SAME
WAY AT ALL THREE OF THOSE
INSTITUTIONS.
SAME FAMILY SAME NEED IN FACT
THAT WAS CAMINO CONSTANT THAT
HAS A CT.
UP UNTIL THIS LAST YEAR THEY
WERE GETTING FIVE HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN DOLLARS TO TAKE THAT CITY
COURSE.
IT WENT UP TO A THOUSAND DOLLARS
BECAUSE WAS IT STILL LESS MACAU
ACT BUT BE ACCESS WHICH IS AT
SIXTEEN SAUDI SO WE'VE DECIDED
THAT THE STATE THAT THEY'RE
WORTH LESS.
FOR GOING TO GET A CT
CERTIFICATE. AND THEY HAVE THE
SAME FINANCIALLY SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO GET AT THAT
REGARDLESS OF THE CHOICE THAT
YOU MAKE WHETHER TO THE PUBLIC
OR PRIVATE INSTITUTION. AND THE
CAREER PATH WHAT YOU WANT TO GO
YOU WILL STILL HAVE. A COST OF
ATTENDANCE THAT MAY OR MAY NOT
BE FULFILL DEPENDING ON WHICH
SEGMENT YOU CHOOSE.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
GET. THAT'S WHAT THIS
HEARINGS ABOUT.
BUT YOUR ANALOGY WE'RE NOT
TRAVELERS FROM ARE OFTEN THE
SAME FAMILY NOT ALL THAT IS
SINGLE WE DEAL WITH PEOPLE FROM.
DIFFERENT COLORS DIFFERENT
SOCIAL BACKGROUNDS TOTALLY
DIFFERENT. THEY COULD BE IN THAT
WHILE WE ARE LOOK LOOK AROUND
AND AND AND THE OTHER ISSUE IS
THAT THE JEWS AND A DIFFERENT
PATHWAYS YES NOT ONE'S BETTER
THAN THE OTHER. YOU KNOW JUST
DIFFERENT PEOPLE GUNNED IT
DIFFERENTLY. IN DIFFERENT WE
FUND THE PATHWAYS DIFFERENTLY
AND AFFECT WE ACTUALLY WE FUND.
THE REQUIREMENT.
THAT'S WHAT RAIMES AND WE NEED
TO LOOK OF FUNDING THE
REQUIREMENT. THAT THE DID BETTER
DIFFERENT JUST FUNDING THE
REQUIREMENT FOR.
JUST IF I'M UP FOR DISCUSSION
AYE DECK AYE THREAT AYE START MY
STATE LIKE SAID THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE.
BUT.
I THINK TO MISTER CHAVEZ'S
FUNDING THE SYSTEMS AND HOW MUCH
YOU PUT IN THE SYSTEM AND THIS
IS JUST THE FINANCIAL AID PIECE.
YEAH AND THAT AS OVER LEARNING
IT'S THIS WEEK THAT'S LIKE ONE
OF OUR PUBLIC SPEAKERS LATER ON
WITH A DAVID TALKED FOR YEARS
ABOUT HOW. YOU'RE A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT AT BERKELEY
VERSUS A THAT SOMEONE AT UC
BERKELEY VERSUS GOING TO CSU
EAST BAY. IS NIGHT AND DAY THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT IS WAY
LESS FINANCIAL AID AND THEY'RE
LIVING IN THE SAME CITY. AND SO
THE TOOLS THAT WE GIVE PEOPLE TO
GO TO COLLEGE.
THAT. ARE ARE VERY DIFFERENT
AND SO I THINK THAT'S THE WHAT
WHICH PART FOR TRYING TO GET OUT
HERE.
YEAH GRAHAM MEMBER THAT
DISCUSSION I THINK SOMEBODY MADE
THE COMMENT I YEAH I GOT A
FRESNO GENE GREEN TO COLLEGE
BERKELEY BUT. WAS A JOKE.
OKAY.
YOU KNOW WE HAD PUBLIC COMMENTS
AT THE END THEIR PICK FOR VERY
DIFFERENT TOPICS TODAY BUT JUST
WANTED TO ASK IS THERE ANYBODY
THAT ONE IT IS.
SPEAK IN PUBLIC COMMENT
SPECIFICALLY.
ABOUT.
THEY SAT AGENDA ITEM ON
REFORMING.
FINANCIAL AID CALIFORNIA IF SO
PLEASE THEM LINEUP.
IS THE CHAIR MEMBER BRIAN HOW
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS.
I WAS BEEN AWHILE SINCE I
ATTENDED THIS COMMITTEE HEARING
TO SUPPORT SOMETHING.
BUT I AM IN FACT TO SUPPORT. OF
DEFEAT THAT IS AND.
ASIDE YOUR DAYS OUT PROPOSAL ON
THE AS AS YOU TO FINANCIAL AID
ON.
COMPLETE REFORM AND WE APPLAUD
YOU.
WILL AFFORD WHAT YOU WITH YOU.
AND DOWN WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ERICA ROMERO BEHALF THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES REPRESENTING THE
NOT FOR PROFIT INSTITUTIONS IN
THE STATE. WE THANK YOU ALL FOR
THIS DISCUSSION AND WE ALSO
THINK THAT.
WRITERS OF THE REPORT AND THE
COMMISSION FOR REMEMBERING THAT
WE HAVE SEVENTY NINE NON FOR
PROFIT INSTITUTIONS IN THAT WE
ARE A VITAL PART OF THE MASTER
PLAN. FOR HIGHER EDUCATION AND
WE URGE YOU AS YOU CONSIDER ANY
FINANCIAL AID PROPOSALS TO
REMEMBER THAT CALIFORNIA'S LOW
INCOME STUDENTS REMAIN YOUR IT
LOW INCOME STUDENTS REGARDLESS
OF WHAT'S UP TO THE CHIPS.
THINK.
THANK YOU MARK MCDONALD.
MCCALLUM GROUP ON BEHALF OF
NUMBER LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS.
PUTTING LAS RIOS KERN FOOTHILL
DE ANZA AND THE SOUTH ORANGE
COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS.
WERE AND IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE
DIRECTION THAT THIS REPORT IS
TAKEN. AND I DO WANT TO SAY ONE
THING THE QUESTION THAT YOU
ASKED ABOUT THE.
ACCESS AWARD WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF INCREASING THE ACCESS
AWARD THIS YEAR AS IS
RECOMMENDED THROUGH THE.
.
THROUGH THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
C. SACK IF YOU'RE GONNA DO IT I
THINK THIS IS THE YEAR TO DO IT.
THE LA THOUGH HAS PROJECTED MORE
REVENUES COMING AT THE MAY
REVISE NOT A LOT GOING TO PROP
NINETY EIGHT. SO THIS IS A GOOD
YEAR TO DO THAT THANK YOU.
SYNDICATES DE ON BEHALF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF C. SACKS
PROPOSAL TO REFORM FINANCIAL AID
AS OUTLINED IN THE RECENT
REPORT.
THE STATE'S FINANCIAL AID
STRUCTURES BEEN WOEFULLY
INEFFICIENT IN ASSISTING
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS AND WE BELIEVE
THE INCREASING THE CAL GRANT BE
ACCESS AWARD. AND CONSOLIDATING
THE STATE'S FINANCIAL AID
STRUCTURE INTO A SINGLE GRAND
SYSTEM ARE TWO OF MANY THAT THEY
LISTA GREAT WAYS AND TO IMPROVE
ACCESS.
IN THIS DISCUSSION WE ALSO WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT AND CONTINUE
ADVOCATING FOR INCREASING CAL
GRANT SEE FOR OUR CITIES
STUDENTS. WITH ALL THE ATTENTION
ON WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND A
STRONG WORK FIRST PROGRAM WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT COSTS ARE
NOT A BARRIER TO ANYONE WANTING
TO ATTEND THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON WAS THAT NEVER
AND ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CAN COLLEGE LEAGUE REPRESENTING
A CALIFORNIA SONY TOOK ME
COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
ALSO WANT TO SHARE STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AT THIS REPORT AND
THE LEADERSHIP OF C. SACRILEGE
HANG OUT AND MORE CONSPECIFIC
SERVING CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. THE
DIRECTION TO LOOK AT EXPECTED
FAMILY CONTRIBUTION IS AN
EXCELLENT WINE ESPECIALLY FOR
CALIFORNIA'S COMING COLLEGE
STUDENTS.
PART OF A COALITION THAT
SUPPORTS A DIRECTION AND ALSO
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS ON AND
THE STEPS TO IMPLEMENT THIS AND
WE HOPE THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT IT
AS WELL THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BRIAN REAVIS ON
BEHALF OF THE EDUCATION TRUST
LAST
I WANTED TO SAY THAT WE WOULD
ASK THAT YOU PLACE A PRIORITY ON
INCREASING THE AXIS AWARD. WE
WOULD AGREE WITH A LOT OF WHAT
MISS ALCALA SAID ABOUT THE NEED
TO INCREASE THE AWARD TO HELP
LOW INCOME STUDENTS WITH THE
COST OF ATTENDANCE. WE SEE IT AS
ONE OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS WITH
REGARD TO WHAT'S KEEPING LOW
INCOME STUDENTS FROM GOING TO
COLLEGE IN SUCCEEDING.
MY NAME IS DEBBIE RAUSCHER AND
I'M WITH JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES
FOR YOUTH AND I'M HERE TO.
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A REQUEST
THAT WAS SUBMITTED BY SENATOR
JIM BELL TO ADD FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY TO EXPAND
SUPPORT FOR FOSTER YOUTH.
BY AGE TWENTY SIX TO EIGHT
PERCENT OF FOSTER YOUTH HAVE
EARNED A COLLEGE DEGREE AND YET
ONLY NINE PERCENT OF FOSTER
YOUTH IN THE COMMUNICABLE SYSTEM
ARE CURRENTLY ABLE TO ACCESS THE
CAL GRANT.
THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS
NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT PROPOSED
POLICY CHANGES THAT WOULD EXPAND
ACCESS TO THE CAL GRANT
SPECIFICALLY FOR FROSTY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THIS REQUEST.
MY NAME'S EGGS EVERY MOUNTAIN
AND I'M A.
FUSS YOUTH ALUMNI AND THE
CURRENT GRADUATE STUDENT OF USC
AND I'M HERE IN FULL SUPPORT OF
THE SB NINE FORTY. THE CAO CAO
GRANT WITH THE THREE PROVISIONS
ARM OF THE PREVIOUS BOSS YOUTH
THAT I WENT THROUGH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. AND I LE RECEIVE MY
BASKET UNIVERSITY OF THE PACIFIC
AND CURRENTLY. I'M STILL DOING
THE SAME BUT WITHOUT CAL GRANT.
THAT CAL GRANT I HAVE THE
DEFTLY WOULD NOT BE WHERE I'M
AT.
AND I DEFTLY THINK A OTHER OF OF
THE OTHER KS YOU DESERVE
SAME OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU.
IT'S TAKE A TIME OUT REAL QUICK
SO JUST REMINDER A ONE MINUTE
APIECE AND ALSO AND WE WELCOME
PUBLIC COMMENT LOOKS LIKE
THERE'S PUBLIC COMING AND. ALL
THE ADS DOUBTS LIST IS GET OUT
THE WASTE IF ANYBODY HAS PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ANY OF THE FOUR ITEMS
TODAY. THIS IS GONNA BE THE
PUBLIC COMMENT SECTION MUZZLE
JUST.
BECAUSE SO.
MY NAME'S TIMOTHY HOPES I'M A
POSSE OUR FORMER BOSS YOU
THROUGH COLLEGE I'M IN SUPPORT
OF THE.
EXPANSION OF CAL GRANT
PREPOSTEROUS REQUESTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DESTINY SIMPSON I'M
CURRENTLY A STUDENT BICU
COMMUNITY COLLEGE I'M A FORMER
FOSTER USE I AM IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THE. REQUEST TO EXPAND THE
GRANT FOR.
.
CAL GRANT FOR THE FOSTER YOU
SPECIFICALLY THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MARCY BAILEY.
I AM A RETURNING. COLLEGE
STUDENT POUND DUE TO. HAVING TO
ACTUALLY DROP OUT BECAUSE F
THINGS LIKE THIS.
I AM FULL SUPPORT OF THIS AND
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD KEEP IT
THAT WAY.
MY NAME IS SARAH THOMPSON I AM
FROM ACROSS USE AND A STUDENT AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND I DO
SUPPORT.
THE REQUEST FOR AN EXTENDED CAL
GRANT.
HI MY NAME'S ALSO YANA ANIMAL
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND ALSO
ATTENDING BICU COLLEGE I AFTER
ALL I AM GONNA GET FINANCIALLY
IT IN INCOME FROM BOTH MY JOBS
TO.
FUN MY SCHOOLING AND I AM IN
FULL SUPPORT FOR THIS BUDGET FOR
THE CAL GRANT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SAMANTHA GRIFFITHS
AND I AM A COLLEGE STUDENT ARE
YOU RIGHT NOW.
I AM ACTUALLY STRUGGLING WITH
FINANCIAL AID HOME I WOULD
REALLY. BENEFIT FROM THIS GRANT
AND I AM IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KIMBERLY MICHAEL I AM
I AM A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND
CURRENTLY AT BUTTE COLLEGE WHEN
I STARTED MY COLLEGE JOURNEY I
WAS EIGHTEEN WITHOUT ANY KIND OF
FAMILY SUPPORTER AND SO THE ONLY
RENT I COULD AFFORD WAS. A HOUSE
WITH NO HEAT OR AIR CONDITIONING
AND I SLEPT ON A MATTRESS THAT I
GOT FOR FREE DOWN THE STREET.
AND SO IN MAY I WILL BE
GRADUATING MY ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE
FROM BUTTE AND I JUST WOULD LIKE
TO SAY THAT I SUPPORT.
MORE FUNDING FOR.
CAL GRANT THANK YOU.
NINE VANCE EDWARD SOME FROWNED
BICU COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND
CAME DOWN HERE AT THE STUDENTS
TODAY TO SUPPORT EXPANSION OF
THE CAL GRANT FOR COST YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S ELIZABETH MCGREGOR
AND I'M A COUNSELOR AT BICU
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR OUR
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH.
AND I'M HERE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR EXTRA EXTENDING THE CAL
GRANT FOR OUR FOSTER YOU
STUDENTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MICHELLE DEAN AND I AM A PROGRAM
ADVISER TO CONSUME THE SERVER
COLLEGE.
FOR THE FOSTER YOUTH PROGRAM
I'M ONE OF THE ISSUES I SEE MOST
SAYS. FINANCIAL ISSUES THAT MY
STUDENTS FACE I'M AS A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH MYSELF I ALSO FACE
THESE ISSUES WHEN I WAS GOING TO
SCHOOL.
AND I CAN TESTIFY THAT WITHOUT
THIS EXTENSION OF CAL GRANT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A LOT LESS
TEAMS THAT ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO COMPLETE THEIR EDUCATIONAL
GOALS SO I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF
THE US THANK YOU.
HI LAURA AS EITHER KEEP ITS AT
THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS
AND SUCCESS I'M AS A LEADER OF A
COALITION OF ORGANIZATIONS
FOCUSED ON COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
IN CALIFORNIA AND MANY OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT THE C. SACK.
REPORT.
DISCUSSES ARE ONES THAT WE ALSO
EXPRESSED CONCERN ABOUT HIM
WHILE WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
DETAILS STILL NEED TO BE
DISCUSSED FURTHER WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE INCREASE TO THE CAL
GRANT THE ACCESS AWARD TO HELP
COVER NON TUITION COSTS. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT TWO DOZEN
ORGANIZATIONS IN OUR COALITION
SUPPORT AS WELL AND SINCE YOU
ALSO ASKED FOR OTHER COMMENTS ON
OTHER AGENDA ITEMS NUMBER FOUR.
I'M JUST WANNA STAY THERE REALLY
APPRECIATIVE THAT THE COMMITTEE
IS CONSIDERING OUR PROPOSAL AND
A RECOMMENDATION ON THE
CONSOLIDATION OF THE TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. I'M
FINANCIALLY PROPOSALS I HAVE
COPIES HERE AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS LATER FOLKS
HAPPEN THINK IT.
HI JAKE PRINTER WITH THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
WE ARE PROUD MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY COALITION LED BY
TI GUESS AND WHEN OUR COMMENTS
REGARDING THE PROBLEMS DISCUSSED
IN THE FEES AKRAPOVIC.
WITH OUR FRIENDS AT TI CUTS
REGARDING THE OTHER AGENDA
ITEMS.
WE ALSO ARE STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
MAINTAIN THE AWARD LEVEL FOR THE
CAL GRANT THAT PRIVATE NONPROFIT
INSTITUTIONS WHILE ALSO PLACING
AN EXPECTATION. ON ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER ADMITS THAT
THOSE INSTITUTIONS AND BUILDING
UP THE SIX THAT'S ABOUT PATHWAY
WE ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
INCREASE TO THE CAL GRANT BE
ACCESS OR. THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU RENDON BIGGER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA'S DO NAY
COMMISSION I'M IN RELATION TO
THE FOSTER YOUTH BUDGET
AUGMENTATION REQUEST THE
COMMISSION DOES HAVE A SUPPORT
POSITION ON THE BILL ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT BUDGET REQUEST.
TO HELP FOSTER YOUTH GAIN MORE
ACCESS TO FINANCIAL AID AND
COMPLETE AND A LOT MORE. I GUESS
CONSISTENT BASIS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
BUT AFTERNOON STEPHANIE I'VE
LEARNED FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LINES OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES REPRESENTING ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NATIONALLY
ACCREDITED.
PROVIDERS MANY MANY MANY OF WHOM
SUPPORT THESE YOUTH
WERE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE FORTY IN EXPANDING ACCESS
TO BE CAL GRANTS.
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU AT
THIS WAS AN INFORMATIONAL ITEM
OR CERTAINLY CONSIDER.
THE.
THE REPORTS AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE FOLLOW
UP.
WHEN WE DO THAT NAY REVISED
DELIBERATIONS SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR. REAR EFFORTS THIS IS THAT.
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO KATHLEEN A CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LOCATION NUMBER TWO THIS IS
RELATED TO. YET GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR CAL GRANT
AWARDS FOR.
PRIVATE NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA
JOH.
KRISTIN STORES WITH THE.
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES.
AND AS SOON EIGHT COMMISSION.
WE GET A BIG THRILL OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF ON.
FINANCE ARTISTS ALL.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PLEASE AND MARY ARE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AS YOUR AGENDA NOTES THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES AN
INCREASE OF SEVEN POINT NINE
MILLION GENERAL FUND TO MAINTAIN
THE MAXIMUM CAL GRANT TUITION
AWARD FOR NEW STUDENTS ATTENDING
PRIVATE NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS.
AT NINE THOUSAND EIGHTY FOUR
DOLLARS WITH A REQUIREMENT THAT
AS A CONDITION OF MAINTAINING
THE HIGHER AWARD AMOUNT. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND EACH
YEAR THEREAFTER PRIVATE
NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS ANNUALLY
ADMIT A SPECIFIED NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WHO HAVE EARNED
TRANSFER DEGREES FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND ARE
GUARANTEED JUNIOR STANDING.
SPECIFICALLY TO MAINTAIN A
HIGHER AWARD AMOUNT THE PROPOSAL
REQUIRES PRIVATE NONPROFIT
INSTITUTIONS AS A WHOLE TO ADMIT
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED ASSOCIATE
DEGREES FOR TRANSFER. STUDENTS
IN TWENTY EIHTEEN NINETEEN
THREE THOUSAND ASSOCIATE DEGREES
FOR TRANSFER STUDENTS AND TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. AND THEREAFTER
THREE THOUSAND ASSOCIATE DEGREES
FOR TRANSFER STUDENTS ADJUSTED
FOR INCREASES IN THE NUMBER OF
COMMITTEE COLLEGE TRANSFER
STUDENTS FROM THE PRIOR PRIOR
YEAR TO THE PRIOR YEAR.
THIS PROPOSAL FURTHER THE GOALS
OF THE STATE'S MASTER PLAN FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION BY EMPOWERING
STUDENTS TO PURSUE AN ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER THAT ALSO
ENSURES THEY ARE ABLE TO
EFFICIENTLY EARNED A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE. THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OKAY THANK
YOU ELLIOTT. AYE JENNIFER KUHN
ALEJO SO THE GOVERNOR HAS TO
PROPOSALS THE FIRST ONE WAS JUST
ENERGY OF SARS MONTAUK WHEN
FIRST WE RECOMMEND REJECTING A
PROPOSAL.
OUR MAJOR CONCERN IS THAT UNDER
THE PROPOSAL BOTH COLLEGES AND
LOW INCOME STUDENTS ARE TREATED
ARBITRARILY SO FOR EXAMPLE UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
FINANCIALLY NEEDY CAO GRANT
RECIPIENT GOING INTO FRESNO
PACIFIC UNIVERSITY FRESNO
PACIFIC UNIVERSITY MAKES A GOOD
FAITH EFFORT THEY INCREASED THE
NUMBER OF EDTA IS. THE SYSTEM
SECTOR Y. DOESN'T MEET THE
ADMINISTRATION'S TARGET BOTH THE
SEGMENT THEM FRESNO PACIFIC
UNIVERSITY AND THE LOW INCOME
STUDENTS IS A REDUCTION IN THEIR
CAL GRANT AWARD. WE RECOMMEND
AGAINST ANY POLICY THAT TREATS
OF FOLKS US ARBITRARILY IS HOW
EFFECTIVELY HOLDING FRESNO
PACIFIC AND THE LONG COME
STUDENT ACCOUNTABLE FOR THINGS
THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF THEIR
CONTROL.
IF YOU WANT THE NONPROFIT SECTOR
IF YOU THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA%
THAT THEY MAKE EFFORTS TO TRY TO
INCREASE TRANSFER STUDENTS.
OR SHOULD TRY TO SPECIFICALLY
INCREASE EIGHTY TIAS I THINK YOU
COULD TAKE MUCH MORE
STRAIGHTFORWARD APPROACH AND
JUST SIGNAL THAT SURE INTERESTS.
AND THEY GET INTO A I SEE YOU
SEE YOU ALREADY AND THAT YOUR
AGENDA IT'S DESCRIBED AS IN THE
MIDST OF WORKING WITH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO DEVELOP
AN AMMO YOU. THAT WOULD HAVE THE
MAKE EFFORTS TO DO A MARKETING
PLAN SOME MORE CALIFORNIANS ARE
AWARE THAT THE TRANSFER PATHWAYS
ACCESSIBLE TO THEM.
YOU CAN ALSO GO FURTHER AND HAVE
A I SEE SEE YOU REPORT BACK A
YEAR FROM NOW ON HOW MANY
TRANSFER STUDENTS DID THEY TAKE
HOW MANY EIGHTY T. STUDENTS
SPECIFICALLY DID THEY TAKE.
RIGHT NOW THE ADMINISTRATION
CAN'T TELL YOU THAT INFORMATION
SO YOU DON'T HAVE A BASELINE SO
YOU DON'T KNOW IF TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED IS A GOOD GOAL OR IF THE
A I CC YOU SECTOR IS ALREADY
ABOVE THAT GOAL. YOUR AGENDA
SPECIFIES THAT I A I SEE SEE YOU
TAKES ABOUT NINETY FIVE HUNDRED
TRANSFER STUDENTS SIERRA COULD
VERY WELL BE THAT TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED OF THEM ARE DO YOU HAVE
ANY DUTY.
SO YOU COULD AGAIN SIGNAL YOUR
INTEREST THAT YOU THINK THIS IS
A GOOD IDEA HAVE A I SEE SEE YOU
REPORT BACK HOPE THAT YOU DO SEE
INCREASES YEAR OVER YEAR FOR THE
NEXT FEW YEARS.
WE CONTINUE TO THINK IT'S GOOD
POLICY THAT AND THE IT'S GOOD
PRACTICE THAT THE STATE HAVE A
POLICY FOR ESTABLISHING WHAT THE
NONPROFIT CAL GRANT SHOULD BE.
THE STAY IN YEARS PAST HAS HAD A
POLICY NOT JUST FOR WHAT'S AT
STAKE FROM GOING FROM AN EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLAR TO NINE THOUSAND
DOLLAR WARD BUT WHAT THE WORD
ITSELF SHOULD BE WHETHER TO BE
NINE THOUSAND.
FOR A FRAME OF REFERENCE WE JUST
TOOK THE STATE'S PRIOR POLICY
TRADITIONALLY THESE POLICIES
HAVE TRIED TO THE VALUES STUDENT
CHOICE STUDENT ACCESS AND COST
NEUTRALITY THAT THE STATE WOULD
PAY THE SAME AMOUNT ON BEHALF OF
THE LOW INCOME STUDENTS. WHETHER
THEY ONCE THE NONPROFIT OR
PUBLIC INSTITUTION SO THE FRAME
OF REFERENCE WE TOOK THE LAST
POLICY THE STATE HAD IN PLACE
JUST UPDATED AT.
THE RATE WOULD BE SIXTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
YOU MIGHT NOT WANT TO GET THERE
OVERNIGHT THAT'S SUBSTANTIALLY
HIGHER THAN THE NINE THOUSAND
DOLLAR PRE.
I AM IF YOU IMPLEMENTED IT OVER
A FIVE YEAR PERIOD WITH TWELVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR INCREMENTAL AWARD
INCREASES IN COSTS ABOUT EIGHT
POINT SIX MILLION A YEAR IN
TOTAL AFTER THE FIVE YEARS IT
BEFORE THE THREE MILLION DOLLARS
MARK. SO THAT'S AGAIN JUST A
REFERENCE IF YOU DID WANT TO
RESURRECT SOME THE OLD POLICIES
THE STATE HAD FOR ESTABLISHING
WHAT DOES THE WORD LEVEL SHOULD
BE.
WELL I'M SO SORRY SO THERE IS A
WHOLE NOTHER PROPOSAL THAT YOU
HAVEN'T TALKED AT ALL ABOUT
YEAH.
FOUNTAIN I THINK I CAN COVERED
AND ONCE YOU MINUTES SO THE
OTHER PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IS THAT IF YOU'RE WASCO
CREDITED FOR PROFIT. YOU WITH
THIS YOU WILL LOSE SO YOU WOULD
GO FROM NINE THOUSAND TO FOUR
THOUSAND THAT LOW INCOME
STUDENTS CAL GRANT RECIPIENTS AT
THOSE INSTITUTIONS WOULD STEVE A
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR REDUCTION
IN THEIR CAL GRANT.
THERE'S ONLY FIVE INSTITUTIONS
THAT WOULD BE AFFECTED.
WE ASK THE ADMINISTRATION
SEVERAL TIMES WHY IT WHY DO THIS
WHAT'S THE RATIONALE AND WE
DIDN'T GET A PARTICULARLY GOOD
ANSWER BUT WE WENT THE EXTRA
STEP INSIDE IT ARE THERE REASONS
WHY YOU MIGHT BE CONCERNS AND
ONCE REDUCE THE AWARD. FROM NINE
THOUSAND TO FOUR THOUSAND FOR
THESE FIVE.
RIGHT NOW THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM
ALREADY HAS INSTITUTIONAL
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA SO THESE
INSTITUTIONS ARE YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A GRADUATE OF AT LEAST
THIRTY PERCENT AND NO MORE THAN
A FIFTEEN POINT FIVE PERCENT
STUDENT DEFAULT RATE. THEY MEET
THOSE CRITERIA.
SO WE WENT FURTHER AND SAID WELL
HOW DO THEY STACK UP AGAINST THE
NONPROFIT SIN AGAINST YES YOU
KNOW. THEIR GROUND RATES ON
AVERAGE THESE FIVE INSTITUTIONS
ARE LOWER THAN THE NON PROFITS
HIGHER THAN CSU SYSTEM WIDE.
WHEN IT COMES TO STUDENT DEFAULT
RATES THEIR HIGHER THAN BOTH NON
PROFITS AND CSU BUT BY ONE
PERCENTAGE POINT ON AVERAGE.
SO UNTIL FOLKS CAN HAVE LIKE
MEANINGFUL INDICATORS THAT THESE
FIVE INSTITUTIONS ARE LOWER
QUALITY WE DON'T THINK THERE'S
ADEQUATE JUSTIFICATION FOR
REDUCING AWARD FOR FINANCIALLY
NEEDY STUDENTS ATTENDING THEM.
AT I KNOW WEEK WEEK WE CLOSED UP
PUBLIC COMMENT BY NO THERE'S
THAT REPRESENTS FROM THE PRIVATE
FOR PROFIT SO. IF THEY DID WANT
TO COMMENT ON THIS PROPOSAL THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WASN'T RIGHT
NOT BUT WE WILL.
AND ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN.
THAT CHAIRMAN IF I MAY GOD CHRIS
FERGUSON WITH FINANCE I THINK
THE REASON THAT YOU'RE NOT
SEEING PLANNING AND SAY THIS AS
A PROPOSAL IS. THAT'S EXISTING
WALL.
SO WE HAVE A PROPOSED A CHANGE
IN THAT AREA THAT IS WHAT LAW
WOULD HAVE. UP FOR THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FISCAL YEAR FOR THE
WALK FOR PROFIT AYE INSTITUTIONS
AND I AYE WHERE MAYBE AT A LOSS
AS FAR AS WHITE IS X. EXISTING
LOCKING YOU. LIGHTNESS THERE'S
WHY THIS IS HAPPENING.
SEARCHLIGHT WHAT HAPPENED
BETWEEN LAST YEAR AND THIS YEAR
WHICH WHICH MAKES THIS HAPPEN SO
TO GIVE YOU A HISTORICAL
PERSPECTIVE AND I BELIEVE THE
TWENTY TWELVE BUDGET ACT THERE
WAS A SET OF AGREEMENTS MADE IT
TO LOWER. AT THE AMOUNT GIVEN TO
THE INSTITUTIONS OF THE RESULT
OF THE RECESSION AND THOSE
DECIDED IN TWENTY TWELVE AND
TWENTY FOURTEEN FIFTEEN THE
AMOUNT WOULD GO DOWN FROM NINE
THOUSAND EIGHT FOUR TWO I
BELIEVE EIGHT THOUSAND FIFTY
SIX.
AND THEN SINCE THE TWENTY
FOURTEEN BUDGET ACT EVERY YEAR
SINCE THEN.
EACH BUDGET ACT HAS SICK PUSHED
BACK THAT DECISION.
EACH YEAR SUCCESSIVELY AND SO.
OUR A FINANCES PERSPECTIVE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PERSPECTIVE
IS THAT THIS IS A FULFILLMENT OF
EXISTING LAW BEING CONSISTENT.
YES SO THERE'S FIVE. COLLEGES
THAT WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE
GENERAL FUND.
IMPACT OF ALL THIS SO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET RECOGNIZES
APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND IN GENERAL FUND
SAVINGS.
A THOUSAND COCA UP UNTIL NOW
ALTHOUGH THAT WAS THE
ARRANGEMENT AND TWELVE THIRTEEN
THAT COME FOURTEEN FIFTEEN ALL
WASCO CREDITED. PRIVATE SCHOOLS
WHETHER THEY BE NONPROFIT OR FOR
PROFIT WOULD SEE THEIR ADOPTION
THE PROPOSAL THIS YEAR IS TO
ACTUALLY TRIGGER AND ALLOW THE
REDUCTION TO OCCUR JUST FOR THE
FOR PROFITS YARDI HEARD ABOUT
THE PROPOSAL FOR THE NON PROFITS
TO KEEP IT AT THE NINE THOUSAND
DOLLAR LEVEL.
OKAY.
THANK YOU TERRY MCCARTY AND
KRISTEN SOURIS AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ALSO CHRISTENSEN
WORRIES THE PRESIDENT OF A ICC
YOU CALIFORNIA'S INDEPENDENT
NOT.
SECTOR.
TODAY MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS AND
NEARLY A HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND GRADUATE STUDENTS
ATTEND A PRIVATE NONPROFIT
COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY IN
CALIFORNIA.
MAKING US LARGER THAN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
SEVENTY FOUR PERCENT OF OUR
UNDERGRADUATES ARE CALIFORNIANS.
LET ME BEGIN BY SHARING WITH
THIS PROPOSAL THAT WE ARE
EXTREMELY GRATEFUL THAT THE
GOVERNOR.
HAS CHOSEN TO REPEAL THE PENDINE
ELEVEN POINT OVER ELEVEN PERCENT
CUT THE MAXIM KALORAMA WORK.
THAT AWARD CUT WOULD HAVE BEEN
APPROXIMATELY OVER A THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER STUDENT.
AND THESE ARE LOW INCOME
STUDENTS WHO WE ALL KNOW HOW TO
OVERCOME INCREDIBLE CHALLENGES.
TO MAKE IT INTO COLLEGE.
SO YOU UNDERSTAND FOR OUR
STUDENTS OUR FAMILIES THE
AVERAGE INCOME FOR A CAL GRANT
THE STUDENT.
FAMILY OF FOUR.
IT'S APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THE AVERAGE INCOME FOR A FAMILY
OF FOUR FOR CAL GRANT A STUDENT
IS APPROXIMATELY FORTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
EVERY DOLLAR COUNTS FOR THE
STUDENTS.
MANY OF WHOM ARE THEIR FIRST IN
THEIR FAMILY TO ATTEND COLLEGE.
WE ARE ALSO LOOKING FORWARD IN
THIS PROPOSAL TO STRENGTHEN OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE AND
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO TRANSFER
STUDENTS SPECIFICALLY RULING
MORE STUDENTS AS YOU PER.
THROUGH THE ASSOCIATE DEGREE OF
TRANSFER PROGRAM.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING AT THE CUNY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR OAKLEY AND
HIS TEAM AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND OUR MEMBER
INSTITUTIONS TO IMPLEMENT THIS.
THIS IS A DECISION THAT THE A I
CC BOARD OF DIRECTORS TOOK VERY
SERIOUSLY.
AND REALIZED IT WOULD BE A
CHALLENGE TO BUILD TO IT. BUT
SAW THE IMPORTANCE OF PROTECTING
OUR LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND ALSO
THE IMPORTANCE OF INCREASING
TRANSFER TO OUR INSTITUTIONS.
AND DESERVING JUNIOR COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND A MUCH MORE
FORCEFUL AND TRANSPARENT WAY.
OUR GOALS ARE ALIGNED.
IN WHICH IS AGAIN TO MAKE THE
TRANSFER PROCESS.
EASIER MORE FRIENDLY AND MORE
TRANSPARENT.
WE BELIEVE THAT INDEPENDENT
COLLEGES AND OUR COMMITMENT TO
STUDENT SUPPORT SERVICES.
AND SUCCESS
MAKE US A VERY GOOD FIT FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRANSFER
STUDENTS.
WE ALSO WANTED THINK THAT WAS
ADDRESSED HERE. THE UNIQUENESS
OF THIS OF THE A AYE FEES
YOU-INSTITUTIONS.
AND TO THE ELLIOTTS RESPONSE
ABOUT THE FPU MAYBE BEYOND A DO
IT THAT ANOTHER INSTITUTION NOT
BEYOND TO APPRECIATE THAT.
BUT WE WORKED OUT ON A SECTOR
WIDE.
GOAL.
KNOWING THAT SOME INSTITUTIONS
WILL HAVE THE ABILITY JOB ADT
MORE QUICKLY AND OTHERS WOULD
NOT AND THERE IS A TARGET NUMBER
HERE.
SO WE WANTED TO BRING THE
COLLECTIVE TO MEET THIS CALL.
SOME MOBILE TO DO IT SOONER SOME
WILL BE ABLE TO DO IT LATER.
I WILL MARIN MIND YOU THAT THE
EIGHTY TEAM. WAS A CURRICULA.
THAT WAS NEGOTIATED BETWEEN THE
FACULTY THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND THE CI SHE'LL.
AND THEY DID A WONDERFUL JOB
WITH THAT.
AND IT'S EVIDENCE BY THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS WHO ARE NOW TAKING
ADT PATHWAY AND IT'S GROWING.
SO WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE C.
ISSUES SO WE ARE TRYING TO MATH
TO THIS CURRICULUM IS.
I'M AS MUCH AS WE CAN.
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM.
AND FUNDING OF ADT.
BUT WE BELIEVE WE WILL SEE A
STRENGTHENED PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE STAY IN SERVING STUDENTS AND
WE KNOW THAT WE NEED TO SERVE
FOR STUDENTS AND WE KNOW THAT
OUR SECTORS PART OF THAT
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THIS
DISCUSSION YOU OUT EARLIER.
AROUND WE DELIVERING VERY
IMAGINATION OF FINANCIAL AID.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ADDRESSED WITH THE
ALLAN. ABBOTT ASK YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WE
KNOW IT'S HARD WE CAN DO IT. I'M
HAPPY TO ADDRESS AT THE EIGHTY
FIVE REPORT.
ON ELEMENTS THAT WERE ALSO IN
THE ANALYSIS IF YOU'D LIKE
RETAIL ON.
OVERALL NUMBERS A TRANSFER
ONLINE EXACT TRUCK THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ETCETERA.
WE THOUGHT I WOULD ESTIMATE
COMMISSION WE'RE GRATEFUL TO THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR MAINTAINING
THE MAXIMUM CAO GRAB FOR
NONPROFIT STUDENTS. AT THE
CURRENT NINE THOUSAND EIGHTY
FOUR DOLLAR LEVEL WE DON'T HAVE
A POSITION ON THIS PROPOSAL TO
LINK THE GRANT AMOUNT THE NUMBER
OF ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER
STUDENTS ENROLLED AT THE.
NONPROFIT SECTOR HOWEVER WERE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE AND AS YOU SEE YOU
ON THE VERIFICATION REQUIREMENT.
ULTIMATELY WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THIS GRANT INCREASES WE ARE
AWARE THAT HAVE LOST VALUE OVER
THE YEARS AND. AS ONE OF OUR.
SORT OF PREMIER PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA IS CHOICE FOR
STUDENTS AND.
LIKE THE ALEJO TALKED ABOUT
THEY MEET ALL THE OTHER
REQUIREMENTS AND HOW THEY HAVE A
PRETTY STELLAR GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT FOR THEIR. LOW
INCOME AN UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS.
OKAY. THANK YOU BEFORE YOU GET
TO.
QUESTIONS WHEN IT TO ALLOW.
PUBLIC.
IT ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY ON THIS.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
JENNIFER TANNAHILL WITH AARON
READING ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
WEST COAST UNIVERSITY AND
AMERICAN CAREER COLLEGE WE WANT
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY.
THE LA O. WE AGREED THAT WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING THE GRANT
AMOUNT FOR THE LOW INCOME
STUDENTS THAT ALSO ATTEND THESE
OF THESE HANDFUL SCHOOLS WEST
COAST BEING ONE OF THOSE. I AM
IT'S JUST IT'S NOT A GOOD POLICY
AND NOT A GOOD WAY TO GO I'M AND
TO IMPACT OF STUDENT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MAP BACK
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
COMMENT I'LL SO.
WOULD LIKE TO ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS WITH ELIA WE TWO ARE
OPPOSED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD REDUCE THE
AMOUNT FOR THESE ARE WASCO
ACCREDITED FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS.
AS WOULD NOTED THEIR METRICS ARE
EXTREMELY SOLID BETTER THAN MANY
OF THE OTHER SCHOOLS THAT ARE
APPROVED BY THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. THEIR GRADUATION
RATES ARE VERY HIGH THEIR
DEFAULT RATES ARE VERY LOW. AND
I WOULD BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T
KNOW. MUCH OF THE DISCUSSION THE
PANEL BEFORE THIS WAS ABOUT
REDUCING STUDENT DEBT.
THE STUDENTS ARE STILL GOING TO
GO TO THE SCHOOLS
THERE THERE'S A REASON THE
STUDENTS GO TO THE SCHOOLS THEY
OFFER A PROGRAM THAT FITS THEM.
AND WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS TAKING
AWAY FUNDS FOR THEM TO GO TO
THOSE SCHOOLS SO WHAT ARE THEY
GONNA HAVE TO DO. THEY'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO TAKE UP MORE DEBT.
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO MAKE A LOT OF
SENSE IT CERTAINLY DOES NOT SEEM
CONSISTENT WITH THE COMMENTS
THAT I HEARD WITH PANEL BEFORE.
AND THE MEMBERS WHO SPOKE ABOUT
THE PANEL BEFORE SO WE WOULD
APPRECIATE YOU OPPOSING.
REDUCING OUR OPPOSING THE
REDUCTION OF FUNDS FOR OUR
SCHOOLS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
MEMBERS GREG DOLLAR FOR THE
FASHION INSTITUTE OF DESIGN
MERCHANDISING.
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ASSOCIATE
OURSELVES WITH THE. REMARKS OF
THE ALEJO ABOUT THE LACK OF A
RATIONALE FOR THE REDUCTION THE
ELEVEN PERCENT CUT IN THE
AWARDS.
RIGHT OFF HAND I'D SAY FIDM
REPRESENTS ABOUT HALF OF ALL
THE.
CAL GRANT.
AWARDS RECEIVING THE MAXIMUM
GRANT.
AND.
WE ALSO HAVE A ARE DO YOU
SCHOOL WITH THEIR ONE OF THE
SCHOOLS WITH A VERY LOW DEFAULT
RATE. OF SIX POINT GA PERCENT
DATA COHORT DEFAULT RATE A SIXTY
PERCENT GRADUATION RATE.
WE CONTRIBUTE. MIGHTILY TO THE
ECONOMY OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND CALIFORNIA A WHOLE. AND NON
OUR STUDENTS DESERVE THE SAME
CONSIDERATION.
AS ANY OTHER CAL GRANT STUDENT
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU I KNOW
THIS IS A WIDE ITEM RIGHT HERE
WE DIDN'T REALLY DIG AS THE
AGENDA BUT. IT JUST KIND OF BEGS
THE QUESTION. THERE IS
ESSENTIALLY IDEAL CUT FURTHER
NON FOR THAT NOT FOR PROFIT. AND
PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES BY TYING IT
TO.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRANSFERS SO
WITH THESE FIVE.
COLLEGES DID DID THEY HAVE A JOB
BUT TRANSFER PROGRAM DUE TO HOW
MANY STUDENTS POTENTIALLY.
WAITER COULD EVER DO TRANSFER
FROM THE COMMITTEE CALL TO THESE
TO THESE INSTITUTIONS
MISTER CHAIR I CAN ONLY SPEAK
FOR THE FASHION INSTITUTE OF
DESIGN MERCHANDISING BUT WE'RE
JUST COMPLETING. A YEAH YEAH
YEAH NOT ARTICULATION AGREEMENT
WITH LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT.
TAKE STUDENTS IN TO OUR.
FOR AIRING GRADUATE PROGRAM
SAID FIDM.
SO YES WE ARE YOU KNOW THE
WORKING VERY CLOSE THE OTHER TWO
BEHIND YOU THINK IT IF THEY GET
A APPLYING.
S. TEN HELL MR BACK.
I DON'T HAVE THE NUMBERS FROM
OUR SCHOOL BUT WE CAN GET THAT
FOR YOU YET MAYBE IF YOU CAN NOT
SURE IF YOU DO THAT MR BACK BUT
IF YOU COULD. HIDDEN COULD WORK
WITH US BECAUSE THAT ESSENTIALLY
WAS WHAT WE.
SPARKED OUT HERE AND IS MAYBE AN
INTRIGUING.
KINDA COMPROMISE TO THIS ISSUE
OKAY AND I'D I HAVE TO ECHO I
MEAN ONE OF THESE TWO SCHOOLS
ARE SEE MEMBERS OF MY
ASSOCIATION AND HAVE TO CONTACT
THE OTHER SCHOOLS TO FIND OUT
WHAT THEIR DATA IS BUT WE'RE
HAPPY TO GET THAT INFORMATION
OKAY. THANK YOU SO FAIR ENOUGH
SO BACK TO THE TO THE MATTER AT
HAND THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
CETAINLY WE'VE BEEN.
YEAH DEALING BATTLING THIS ISSUE
FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS AND.
ARE YOU ARE YOU GONNA STILL
GONNA COME VISIT US. STRUCK A
SOURCE THAT IF THIS IF THIS
HAPPENS THIS YEAR WE HAVE
TREMENDOUS NEEDS IN THE STATE
HIM BELIEVE AYE INSTITUTIONS CAN
HELP FILL THEM. THE ANSWER IS
YES BUT A STAPLE OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR FOUR YEARS AND
SO HATE TO SEE.
A TO SEE YOU GO HUESO.
I I KNOW THERE IS STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS ISSUE LAST YEAR
WAS SO STRONG THAT WE WANTED TO
TAKE ACTION.
I THINK THIS TIME OF THE YEAR
DIDN'T WAIT TILL THE MAY REVISE.
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T THINK IT MADE
SENSE AND YOU KNOW.
THE SAME THING THIS YEAR I I AM
PLEASED THAT I KNOW THERE WAS.
SOME.
KIND OF BANKS LAST YEAR FROM
THE ASSOCIATION AS FAR AS
DEALING WITH THE UC COMMITTEE
CALLED TRANSFERS BUT IT'S WHAT
WE REALLY NEED TO DO HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I DO HAVE ONE
QUESTION SO. IT IT IS SOMEWHAT
AWKWARD BECAUSE.
IN THAT CSU FOR EXAMPLE IS
TWENTY THREE IF ONE CHANCELLOR
THAT THE CAT AT THE
JOE WHAT TO DO SAME BUT THE UC
BUT.
THERE IS.
YET THEY'RE ALL HE SERVED HERE A
DISTANT RELATIVES IN YOUR
ASSOCIATION I HAVE A FAMILY SO
HOW DO YOU. HOW DO WE ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY?
WELL AND THE MOM.
IT THAT'S A REALLY EXCELLENT
QUESTION BECAUSE WE ARE A
COLLECTIVE ORGANIZATION AND AS
SUCH I. WE DO JUST AS A MAJOR
DECISION MAKING.
THROUGH OUR BOARD HOWEVER I DO
NOT HAVE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE NOR
CAN I. AND I TELL AN INSTITUTION
WHAT TO DO SO THIS TRULY HAS
BEEN A COLLABORATIVE EFFORT. BY
INSTITUTIONS WHEN WE LOOKED AT
THIS MORE WORK IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE REALLY LOOKED AT THE
NUMBER OF INSTITUTIONS ARE DOING
TRANSFER NOW. THOSE WHO COULD
LOOK AT THE CURRICULUM. AND I
PROVIDE THIS ACCESS SO THIS IS
LIFTING US UP TOWARD THE GOAL.
I'VE IT'S GONNA TAKE A LOT OF
WORK AND IT'S GONNA TAKE SOME
FLEXIBILITY RECOGNIZING AS YOU
JUST SAID I CHAIR MCCARTY THAT
WE. ON DON'T HAVE THAT EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE BUT WE BELIEVE THROUGH
THE GOOD GUYS. THE INFORMATION
WE HAVE.
WHAT WILL BE ABLE TO COLLECT
FROM INSTITUTIONS AND A STRONG
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT WILL VALID EXECUTE
THIS? I WILL SAY THIS WILL TAKE
A VERY STRONG WORKING
RELATIONSHIP Y. THAT AND THAT'S
WHY AN MOU IS BEING NICK.
HOT DISCUSSED AND WORKED ON
BECAUSE THIS WILL TAKE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ALSO.
I SHARING INFORMATION ABOUT THE
ADT NOW AVAILABLE AT A IC CEO SO
GETTING TO THIS GOAL WILL
REQUIRE. THAT STUDENTS KNOW
ABOUT IT AND ACCESS THAT THIS
WILL BE A PARTNERSHIP.
OKAY THANK YOU QUESTIONS.
I SEEING NONE THIS. ISSUE WILL
HOLD OFF AS WELL.
CHILDREN MAY REVISION ISSUE
NUMBER THREE.
CIVILITY EARLIER THIS IS A
STUDENT COMMISSION'S PROPOSAL
AND IN THE.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TEN PAPER
FINANCE LETTER REALLY TO.
FIVE POINT
FIVE MILLION.
TO.
AUGMENTIN.
AND.
.
THAT
IMPROVE THE GRANT DELIVERY
SYSTEM.
SO AS YOUR AGENDA NOTES THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES TO
FUND THE FIRST YEAR OF PROJECT
COSTS FOR THIS YOU NEED
COMMISSIONS GRANTED EVERY SYSTEM
MODERNIZATION PROJECT. AND A
RECENT APRIL FINANCE LETTER
REDUCE THE AMOUNT NECESSARY FOR
THESE COSTS BY ONE POINT NINE
MILLION FOR A TOTAL COSTS OF
FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION IN THE
BUDGET YEAR.
THE GRANTED EVERY SYSTEM IS THE
MEANS BY WHICH SEE SACRAMENTO'S
IS OVER TWO BILLION IN FINANCIAL
AID FOR OF MOST OF THE STATE'S
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS. THE
LARGEST OF WHICH IS THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM.
THE SYSTEM ALSO PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR EXTERNAL USERS SUCH AS
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID
ADMINISTRATORS ACROSS ALL THREE
PUBLIC SEGMENTS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
AND HIGH SCHOOL STAFF TO PROVIDE
STUDENT INFORMATION NECESSARY TO
PROCESS FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATIONS.
AS THE FINANCIALLY PROGRAMS HAVE
EXPERIENCED GROWTH IN RECIPIENTS
AND STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS THEIR
COMPLEXITY HAS BECOME A STRAIN
ON A SYSTEM THAT IS OVER FIFTY
YEARS OLD.
THIS PROPOSAL WILL ALLOW FOR A
NEW AND MODERN SYSTEM THAT WILL
SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION OF
CURRENT PROGRAMS WITHOUT THE
DELAYS AND DISRUPTIONS THAT
PLAGUE THE CURRENT ONE WALLS
HAVE BEEN DYNAMIC ENOUGH TO
SUPPORT NEW PROGRAM APARTMENTS.
CHANGES IN ADMINISTRATION AND
ADDITIONAL LEGISLATIVE
REQUIREMENTS.
THE DECREASE COSTS AS A RESULT
OF WORKING WITH DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY STAFF TO EXPLORE
ALTERNATIVES FOR STRUCTURING THE
PROPOSED PROJECT AND THE RESULT
WAS A MORE COST EFFECTIVE
APPROACH. THAT RELIED ON OPEN
SOURCE SOFTWARE AS OPPOSED TO
PROPRIETARY SOFTWARE. WE
CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE PROJECTS
TIMELINE AND WILL CONTINUE TO
EXERCISE OVERSIGHT AS THEY BEGIN
PROCURING THE PROJECT COMPONENTS
FROM VENDORS.
THANK YOU LA HAVE. AND WE DON'T
HAVE ANY CONCERNS AS.
OF REFINED IN APRIL LETTER SO
IT'S AN OLD SYSTEM ITS CLUNKY
IT'S BEEN CRASH SCENE LAST YEAR
ACROSS TWENTY FIVE TIMES DURING
THOSE TIMES STUDENTS CAN'T
SUBMIT THEIR APPLICATIONS THE
SIXTIES THAT CAN'T MAKE
PAYMENTS.
THEY.
HAVE THE C. SACK WITH THIS IT
PROJECT HAS GONE THROUGH ALL OF
THE STATE'S REVIEW PROCESS
SEASON OVERSIGHT PROCESS IS IS
ACTUALLY THE MOST RECENT CHANGE
HAS BEEN TO REDUCE ESTIMATED
COSTS BY BIFURCATING THAT. THE
ONLY THING WE WOULD NOTE IS THAT
IT IS GOING TO TAKE A COUPLE OF
YEARS TO IMPLEMENT IT SO YOU'RE
SEEING A REQUEST NOW FOR FIVE
AND A HALF MILLION YOU'LL SIERRA
COSTS NEXT YEAR FOR ABOUT FIVE
MILLION AS WELL. OKAY THANK YOU.
STATECOMMISSION LIBBY THANK
ALLY WITH US CALVINIST YOU NEED
COMMISSION WERE VERY GRATEFUL TO
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR INCLUDING
THIS FUNDING IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL. AND ADDITION I
WANT TO SAY THAT WE'VE BEEN VERY
GRATEFUL TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THE. GUY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY FOR ASSISTING US
THROUGH THIS PROCESS A NEW GRAD
DELIVERY SYSTEM WILL NOT JUST BE
MORE EFFICIENT AND COST
EFFECTIVE FOR THE STATE IN THE
LONG RUN BUT IT WILL BE MORE
USER FRIENDLY. MORE RELIABLE
MORE SECURE FOR OUR STAKEHOLDERS
NOT JUST TUNES BUT THE THOUSANDS
OF HIGH SCHOOL COUNSELORS AND
COLLEGE FINANCIAL AID OFFICERS
TO WHOM WE INTERACT ON A DAILY
BASIS. I DO HAVE A WITH ME TODAY
GREATER PAINS ARE CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER.
TO ANSWER ANY MORE DETAILED
QUESTIONS BUT I ALSO WANT TO
THANK HIM TO STOP WE WERE. AS A
RESULT OF THEIR WORK WE'RE ABLE
TO REDUCE THE ESTIMATE FIRST
YEAR PROJECT COST BY NEARLY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS WITHOUT
SACRIFICING THE QUALITY. AND OR
THE RELIABILITY OF THE PROJECT
ITSELF
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
NOW WE SPOKE ABOUT THIS LAST
YEAR WE KNOW THE NEED SO WE
REALIZE WE NEED TO.
FOCUS ON FINDING IT FOR THE NEXT
TWO YEARS.
WE WILL HOLD THE ISSUE OPEN
EXCEL.
LATER ON.
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR FINALISTS TO
THIS IS THE AYE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES
STUDENT SUCCESS COMPLETION GRANT
THIS IS A. PRIORITY OF. THE
ASSEMBLY. LAST YEAR.
WELL THE SENATE.
PROGRAMS AND THEY WANTED.
STREAMLINED.
IT SEEMS.
WITH A GOOD IDEA.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
SOCIAL NEW IN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR A FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAM CALLED THE STUDENT
SUCCESS.
COMPLETION GRANT.
THE PROPOSED PROGRAM
CONSOLIDATES TO EXISTING
PROGRAMS THE FULL TIME STUDENT
SUCCESS GRANT IN THE COMPLETION
GRANT. AND INCLUDES AN
AUGMENTATION OF THIRTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND. TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL AID
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
THE FULL TIME STUDENT SUCCESS
GREAT CURRENTLY PROVIDES AN
AWARD FOR STUDENTS WHO QUALIFY
FOR CAL GRANT AND TAKE TWELVE OR
MORE UNITS PER SEMESTER. AND
COMPLETION GRAHAM PROVIDES AN
AWARD FOR STUDENTS TAKING
FIFTEEN OR MORE UNITS PER
SEMESTER AND WHO QUALIFY FOR A
FULL TIME STUDENT SUCCESS GRANT.
INSTEAD OF FINDING TWO SEPARATE
PROGRAMS THAT TARGET THE SAME
SOCIO ECONOMIC COHORT AND HAVE
DIFFERING REQUIREMENTS THE
BUDGET PROPOSES TO CONSOLIDATE
THE PROGRAMS.
AND CREATE A MORE STREAMLINED
AND STUDENTS FOCUSED PROGRAM.
UNDER THE PROPOSAL A STUDENTS
GRANT AMOUNT WOULD BE BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF UNITS THAT IS
STUDENT TAKES EACH SEMESTER OR
EACH YEAR.
QUALIFYING STUDENTS WOULD
RECEIVE A GRAND IF THEY TAKE.
TWELVE AND FIFTEEN UNITS PER
SEMESTER. OR TWENTY FOUR AND
THIRTY UNITS PER YEAR.
THE LEVEL OF THE GRANT INCREASES
FOR EACH ADDITIONAL UNIT THAT IS
STUDENT TAKES PER SEMESTER.
SPECIFICALLY STUDENTS TAKING
TWELVE UNITS PER SEMESTER WOULD
RECEIVE A THOUSAND PER YEAR
THIRTEEN UNITS WOULD RECEIVE A
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY PER
YEAR.
FOURTEEN UNITS WOULD RECEIVE
NINETEEN HUNDRED PER YEAR AND
FIFTEEN OR MORE UNITS WOULD
RECEIVE FOUR THOUSAND PER YEAR.
AND WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS.
ALEJO'S.
WE RECOMMEND PROJECTING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND WE LAID
OUT AN ALTERNATIVE IN OUR
ANALYSIS FOR YOU AND SO THE
ALTERNATIVE COSTS MORE. I'LL GET
AT THAT.
WE THINK IT'S BETTER POLICY AND
YOU COULD PHASE IT IN OVER TIME.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IT COSTS MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED MILLION MORE
THAN WHAT WE EXISTING AS A STATE
SPEND FOR COMMITTEE COLLEGE
STATE AID IF YOU PHASE IT IN
OVER FIVE YEARS IT WOULD BE AN
AUGMENTATION OF ABOUT FORTY
MILLION A YEAR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING THIS YEAR AGAIN
AUGMENTATION OF. THIRTY THREE
MILLION.
SO I AM ALTHOUGH IT COST
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE IT DOES
SUBSTANTIAL STREAMLINING AND
AGAIN IT MEETS.
BUT BUILT OFF OF MANY OF THE
PRINCIPLES THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER SO FOCUSES ON TOTAL COST
OF ATTENDANCE NOT JUST TUITION.
IT COVERS STUDENTS IF THEY HAVE
ANY UNMET NEED IN OUR
FINANCIALLY NEEDY NOT JUST THOSE
WHO MEET CERTAIN AGE OUR GPA
REQUIREMENTS.
I KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
THERE'S ABOUT SIXTY THOUSAND CAL
GRANT RECIPIENTS WHO WOULD GET
ONE OF THE NEW DOLLAR AMOUNTS
I'M BUT ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
STUDENTS WHO WON AND I GET ANY
AWARD FOR NON TUITION COSTS.
MOST OF THE FOLKS NOT STUDENTS
ASSISTANCE IT'S BECAUSE OUR TO
ALL THEIR MORE THAN ONE YEAR OUT
OF COURT OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL.
I AM SO WE RECOMMEND STREAMING
STREAMLINED THE PROGRAM.
CREATING ONE PROGRAM ONE SET OF
RULES AGAIN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ALTHOUGH IT'S COUCHED
AS CONSOLIDATION TAKES TO AWARD
AMOUNTS AND CREATES FORWARD
AMOUNTS JUST FOR A VERY SELECT
GROUP OF STUDENTS.
AND EVEN WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
WILL WHY WOULD THE STATE WHAT'S
THE PUBLIC POLICY BENEFIT OF
MOVING FROM TWELVE UNITS TO
THIRTEEN UNITS WHY IS NOT WORTH
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS.
DON'T REALLY GET VERY CLEAR AND.
A CLIFF SORT OF A CLEAR
EXPLANATION AS TO WHY THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL. AND IF YOU THINK
ABOUT THE STUDENTS CALCULUS IF I
TAKE THE ONE EXTRA UNIT THAT'S
THREE EXTRA HOURS ON EITHER IN
COSTS ARE DOING HOME WHERE. I
COULD WORK THOSE THREE HOURS AND
MAKE FOR MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS DURING THE SCHOOL
YEAR.
I'M SO INSTEAD OF ALL THAT WE
USE JUST ONE PROGRAM ONE
STREAMLINED SET OF RULES IT
WOULD START WITH THE TOTAL COST
OF ATTENDANCE. IT WOULD BACK OUT
THE STUDENT FAMILIES EXPECTED
CONTRIBUTION UNDER THE STANDARD
NATIONWIDE MEANS TASKS.
AND THEN IT WOULD ASSUME EVERY
STUDENT WORKS FIFTEEN HOURS A
WEEK YOU CAN MAKE A TIME YOU
COULD MAKE IT TWENTY RESEARCH
SAYS THAT IF STUDENTS WORK
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TEN AND TWENTY
ACTUALLY THE ACADEMIC AND. OUT
OUTCOMES ARE GOOD THEY CAN EVEN
IMPROVE.
WE ASSUME NO STUDENT BORROWING
DO NOT USE GOING FULL TIME.
AND IS ONLY WORKING FIFTEEN
HOURS A WEEK THEY WON'T EARN
ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO COVER THE
FULL COST OF ATTENDANCE.
SO WE.
.
I GET AGAIN UNDER THE PROPOSAL
WHETHER YOU'RE NINETEEN ONE YEAR
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL AND HAVE
UNMET NEED OR WHETHER YOU'RE
TWENTY NINE AND HAVE UNMET NEED
AND YOUR LIVES INDEPENDENTLY
YOU'RE LIVING AT HOME YOU HAVE
DEPENDENTS. TIME YOU DON'T HAVE
DEPENDENTS ALL OF THOSE STUDENTS
IF THEY HAVE UNMET NEED WOULD
QUALIFY FOR AID.
IT WILL COST FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION THE STATE TODAY PROVIDES
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR MILLION
AN AID FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
STUDENTS
SO TWO HUNDRED SOME MILLION MORE
SO IF YOU DON'T WANT TO DO THIS
OVERNIGHT. YOU WOULD THINK ABOUT
PRIORITIZING YOU COULD STAR AND
JUST SAY WELL WE'RE GONNA DO ALL
UNMET NEED FOR THOSE STUDENTS UP
UNTIL FIFTY THOUSAND AND THE
NEXT YEAR WILL TRY TO GET UP TO
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND EXCITER OF.
OR YOU COULD SAY THIS YEAR WE'RE
JUST GONNA COVER SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF OUR NET MIGHT NEED A
NEXT I WILL TRY TO GET UP TO
EIGHTY PERCENT. IF YOU USE THE
LATTER APPROACH YOU'RE
EFFECTIVELY SAYING YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO WORK A LITTLE BIT MORE
THAN FIFTEEN HOURS ARE YOU GONNA
HAVE TO TAKE OUT AND OUT TO MEET
THE REST OF THOSE ON TUITION
COSTS.
REGARDLESS WE THINK IT'S BETTER
POLICY IT'S EASIER FOR STUDENTS
AND ADMINISTRATORS TO
UNDERSTAND.
ALTHOUGH THE AGENDA HIGHLIGHTS
MANY ADVANTAGES OF A STREAMLINED
PROGRAM IT DOES HIGHLIGHT THREE
CONCERN THERE WON'T SPEND JUST A
MOMENT REACTING TO THOSE THREE
CONCERNS SO ONE IS THAT.
.
WHY I CREATE A PROGRAM FOR THE
COLLEGES AS OPPOSED TO JUST
REWRITE CAO GRANTS AS WE KNOW IT
YOU COULD YOU COULD REWRITE THE
PROGRAMS THAT EXIST TODAY FOR
ALL STUDENTS?
YOU COULD USE THE SAME APPROACH
THAT WE'VE LAID OUT HERE IS VERY
SIMILAR TO THE UC APPROACH.
AND ALL WE'RE SUGGESTING IS
ALTERNATIVELY YOU COULD START
WITH ONE STATEMENT AND YOU COULD
DO WITH THE STATEMENT THAT HAS
THE GREATEST UNMET NEED.
THERE'S A CONCERN THAT MAYBE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FINANCIAL AID
ADMINISTRATORS JUST WILL WON'T
BE ABLE TO FIGURE THIS THING
OUT.
BUT I THINK IT'S LEFT ADAM
STARTED TO BE SAD WHETHER THE
NEW PROGRAM WITH ONE SET OF
RULES IS ACTUALLY GOING TO BE
ANYMORE COMPLICATED THAN THE
FORCE THAT'S OF EXISTING RULES
ON EXISTING PROGRAMS FINANCIAL
AID ADMINISTRATORS HAVE TO DEAL
WITH TODAY.
AND THE FINAL POINT WAS SOME OF
THIS MONEY RIGHT NOW IS BEING
SCORED TO NINETY EIGHT AND NINE
NINETY EIGHT AND I GET THAT
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
PROPOSAL SOMETHING LIKE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR MILLION
A SPORT SAID NINETY EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO MILLION
SCORED TEN ON. NINETY EIGHT BUT
OBVIOUSLY IT'S JUST MAKE THE
POLICY BASED ON THE STUDENTS YOU
WANT TO SERVE AND FIGURE OUT THE
ACCOUNTING YOU CAN SCORE TO THE
OUTSIDER THAT SIDE BUT THAT
SHOULDN'T BE THE DRIVER OF THE
PUBLIC.
OKAY BEFORE WE GET TO ON.
AND CA COMMISSION INCOMMUNICADO
JUST BEFORE I FORGET THIS POINT
HAD DO YOU FOCUS ON.
SCORING IT.
IT WILL BE WHAT WOULD YOU DO
WITH THAT.
COMMITTEE COLLEGE PROP NINETY
EIGHT BUDGET.
TO DO THIS AND WHAT ALL THE SITE
ON HOW YOU WANTED TO DO IT YOU
COULD FIND OUT FROM ANY SOURCE
RIGHT NOW YOU'VE GOT CAL GRANT
MONEY THAT'S NON NINETY EIGHT
THAT WE WOULD PULL INTO FUND THE
STREAMLINED PROGRAM AND PROP
NINETY EIGHT MONEY. THAT YOU
WOULD PULL THEM OUT IS THAT THE
NEW NINETY EIGHT MONEY.
WHERE WOULD YOU GET IT FROM?
YES THIS IS EXACTLY WHY WE
SUGGEST YOU MIGHT NOT WANT TO DO
IT OVERNIGHT IT OR YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THIS IN THE
CONTEXT OF ALL YOUR OTHER
PRIORITIES YOU WILL BE TAKING UP
FROM SOME OTHER PROP NINETY
EIGHT PRIORITY. OR SOME OTHER
STATE PRIORITY THAT'S OBVIOUSLY
THE STAKES OF IF YOU WANTED TO
GO DOWN THIS ROAD YOU HAVE TO
FIND THE MONEY IT COMES FROM
SOMEWHERE. IS GOING TO COME FROM
SOMETHING ELSE YOU WANT TO BE
ABLE TO DO.
YEAH THAT ONLINE IDEA. AND.
OKAY. NEVER MIGHT.
.
MANY COLLEGES RIGHT CRISSCROSS
WHENEVER THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE.
AGAIN WE APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
STREAMLINE THAT THE NEWLY
CREATED PROGRAMS AS DISCUSSED
EARLIER MAKING FINANCIALLY IT
EASIER TO UNDERSTAND WILL MAKE
IT MORE LIKELY THAT THE FUNDS
WOULD HAVE THEIR INTENDED IMPACT
WHICH IS ENCOURAGING BEHAVIOR
THAT LEADS TO. CULTURAL
POLLUTION.
I DID WANT TO LINK IT TO THE
PREVIOUS DISCUSSION SOME OF
THESE TO PROGRAMS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT STUDENTS WHO CURRENTLY
RECEIVE THE CALGARY HAPPY SO FOR
CONTEXT. WE HAVE ABOUT A MILLION
STUDENTS RECEIVE THE COLLEGE
PROMISED GRANTS BUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND THOSE ONE IN TEN
RECEIVED A TELEGRAM PIECE SO WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT. FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS THAT MEET THE NEEDS OF
A SUBSET OF STUDENTS.
THAT SAID ALL AT OUR
CONCURRENCE THAT WHEN STUDENTS
ARE ON A GUIDED PATHWAYS AND
WHEN THEY HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
DO SO TAKING FIFTEEN UNITS AKE
SENSE AND IT SUPPORTS THE GOALS
WE'VE INCLUDED IN THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS.
WE I'M GONNA GET IN THE WEEDS WE
WANTED OUT JUST A FEW TECHNICAL
ISSUES THAT HAVE COME UP AS
WE'VE IMPLEMENTED THESE TWO
PROGRAMS THE PAST FEW YEARS. IN
AS WE'VE DISCUSSED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WITH OUR
COLLEGES.
FIRST THE COMPLETION GRANT
REQUIRES THAT STUDENTS.
HAVE COMPLETED AN EDUCATION
PLAN AS A CONDITION OF RECEIVING
THE FUNDS.
AND AND I WOULD SAY THE GUIDED
PATHWAYS FRAMEWORK EXPECTS THAT
STUDENTS HAVE AN EDUCATIONAL
GOAL UP FRONT THAT THERE PUTTING
THEM ON PATHWAYS. TO MEET THOSE
GOALS FOR COMMITTED TO MAKING
SURE THAT STUDENTS ARE PLANTS
THAT REFLECT THOSE SCHOOLS.
WITHOUT SAID AS WE'VE
IMPLEMENTED THE COMPLETION GRANT
WE FOUND THAT IT'S OFTEN
DIFFICULT FOR THE PLANTS TO
REACH THE FINANCIAL AID OFFICES
TO ALLOW FOR STUDENTS TO BE
PAID.
OTHER FINANCIAL AID IN A TIMELY
WAY AND WERE WELL WE'RE WORKING
TO IMPROVE COORDINATION AND
THAT'S A KEY PART OF GUIDED
PATHWAYS TO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT STUDENTS WHO CAN GET THEIR
FINANCIAL AID EARLY. AND A WHAT
MAKES THE MOST DIFFERENCE SO I
THINK WE
WE HOPE THAT WE HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH YOU ABOUT
THAT.
SECOND THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
SPECIFIES DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
FUNDING BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
UNITS
OUR EXISTING SYSTEM RIGHT NOW IS
SET UP TO WARD FINANCIAL AID
BASED ON SOME THRESHOLDS THREE
SIX NINE. TWELVE FIFTEEN UNITS
AND SO SETTING UP SYSTEMS THAT
ARE JUST FINANCIAL AID PER UNIT.
IT'S NOT AN INSIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE READ HAVE BOTH ONE
TIME WORKLOAD TO PROGRAM SYSTEMS
AND SOME ONGOING PROCESS IS THAT
WE NEED TEMPLATE TO MONITOR UNIT
BY UNIT CHANGES AND STUDENTS
COURSE TAKING BEHAVIOR.
SO I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT.
WE THINK STILL ARE IT MAKES
SENSE THAT STUDENTS THAT IF THEY
CAN ON PATHWAYS TO TAKE FIFTEEN
UNITS TO TRANSFERRING COMPLETE
IN A TIMELY WAY. WE THINK IT'S
SO IMPORTANT TO THINK ABOUT THE
BALANCE BETWEEN THESE UNITS
SPECIFIC INCENTIVES.
WITH ADMINISTERING THE COSTS IN
A IN AN EFFICIENT WAY.
WE'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
WE'LL BE BACK ALLOW BEHALF OF
THE CONFERENCE TO NAY COMMISSION
AS WE DISCUSSED EARLIER THE
COMMISSION IS GENERALLY
SUPPORTIVE OF EFFORTS TO
CONSOLIDATE AND SIMPLIFY
FINANCIALLY WHEREVER POSSIBLE WE
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE INVESTING IN
ITS ADDITIONAL GRANT AID. FOR
COMEY COLLEGE STUDENTS WE
RECOGNIZE THAT COMMITTEE COLLEGE
STUDENTS OFTEN RECEIVE THE LEAST
SUPPORT FOR NON TUITION COSTS
SUCH BOOKS SUPPLIES AND LIVING
COSTS.
WE SUPPORT ANY EFFORT TO
ENCOURAGE ON TIME GRADUATION
TRANSFER THE COMMISSION
RECOGNIZES THAT THE EXPECTATIONS
REPLACE INSTANCE IS OFTEN NOT
MATCHED BY THE RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT SYSTEMS AVAILABLE TO
THEM. INCENTIVIZING ON TIME
GRADUATION THROUGH INCREASED AID
AS WELL AS COUNSELLING ACADEMIC
SUPPORT SERVICES IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN IMPROVING CALIFORNIA'S
COLLEGE EXPERIENCE. AS ONE IT
TAKE US BACK TO THE VERY FIRST
CONVERSATION WE HAD AND.
TO TRULY CONSIDER THIS PROPOSAL
ALONG WITH THE OVERALL GENERAL
PROPOSAL ABOUT CONSOLIDATING
FINANCIAL AID FOR ALL STUDENTS
AND WHAT THAT MEANS AND. I'M
REALLY CONSIDERING YOU KNOW MANY
OF THE EFFORTS THAT EVEN ARE
HERE TODAY ARTS WERE PIECE
BILLION BECAUSE WE'RE UNDER
FUNDING US SEGMENT OF STUDENTS
THAT SEVERELY NEED IT SO. A WHAT
CAN WE DO TO ENSURE THAT.
THERE'S A HOLISTIC APPROACH FOR
ALL FIVE SEGMENTS AND YOU REALLY
NEED TO CONSIDER WHO.
YOU KNOW WHO ADMINISTERS IT AND.
AND AND THE ACCOUNTABILITY
BEHIND IT WHICH OBVIOUSLY.
YOU'RE TAKING ALL THIS INTO
CONSIDERATION AT THIS HEARING.
OKAY.
QUESTIONS FROM.
TO MANY MEMBERS.
THE KIND OF STARTED OUT ON THIS
EARLIER AT.
IT IS.
IN THIS ITEM BUT ALSO ON THE FOR
SIDE OF SELF.
WE'LL EVALUATE THESE TO PROPOSAL
SAY WE HAVE WITH THE WITH THE
MARY VISION AND LOOK AT WAYS TO.
ESSENTIALLY EXPAND FINANCIAL AID
IN A FEW WEEKS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
THINKING.
THAT WE WILL ADJOURN